Zoe Chace.
佐伊·蔡斯。
Ira Glass.
艾拉·格拉斯。
So you went to Iowa.
所以你去爱荷华州了。
I did. You know, there are like 50,000 Democratic candidates running for president. They're all in Iowa.
是的。你知道，有大约50,000名民主党候选人正在竞选总统。他们都在爱荷华州。
It's what? It's 25 right now.
是多少？现在有25个了。
It's 25 right now.
现在有25个。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
And there's this one political writer, Dave Weigel with the Washington Post, he writes this newsletter thing called The Trailer three times a week. And he has this particular superpower where somehow, he seems to be with every single candidate who's running at the exact same time.
还有一位政治作家，《华盛顿邮报》的戴夫·维格尔，他每周写三次名为《预告片》的通讯。他有一种特殊的天赋，不知何故，他似乎总能同时出现在每一位正在参选的候选人身边。
So at this moment, where everything seems like this grand 25 ring circus with this race, he seemed like maybe the very best person in the world to watch this with. When there's the next president, he'll have seen every moment, not skipping anything. Hopefully, he will understand why it happened.
所以在这一刻，当这场竞选看起来像是一场宏大的25环马戏团表演时，他似乎是世界上最适合一起观看这一切的人。当下一任总统产生时，他将见证每一个时刻，不遗漏任何东西。希望他能理解这一切发生的原因。
And so you basically wanted to see the whole election all at once the way he does.
所以你基本上是想和他一样，一次性看完整个选举过程。
Yeah. And it's so crazy traveling through primary states with him. He knows these places so well. In Iowa, we pulled up to a gas station.
是的。和他一起走访初选州真是太疯狂了。他非常了解这些地方。在爱荷华州，我们把车开到了一家加油站。
If I had to rank Iowa gas stations, I think QuikTrip, then Kum & Go, then Casey's.
如果非要给爱荷华州的加油站排名，我想是QuikTrip，然后是Kum & Go，最后是Casey's。
Wait. So what's so great about QuikTrip?
等等。QuikTrip有什么好的？
The current ones, the fairly new ones-- there are some that have been there for a while. But the new ones, I think it might have high quality lids that are like high quality plastic, as opposed to the thing that just breaks--
现在的那些，比较新的那些——有些已经开了很久了。但我认为新的那些，可能杯盖的质量很高，是那种高质量的塑料，而不是那种用一次就坏的——
Lids?
杯盖？
--after one use. Yeah, lids. And keep in mind. This is the only taste I'm going to have for a few hours, and I need the caffeine. So I've put thought into it. And I have colleagues who are--
——用一次就坏。是的，杯盖。记住，这可能是我几个小时内唯一能喝到的东西，我需要咖啡因。所以我考虑过这个问题。我有一些同事——
We were leaving a Hickenlooper event and racing over to a Beto event.
我们要离开一场希肯卢珀的活动，赶往一场贝托的活动。
Beto is a former Texas senatorial candidate, Beto O'Rourke. Hickenlooper, John Hickenlooper, former Colorado governor-- it took me so long to read up on all these guys. It took like a day to figure out who's who. Yes.
贝托是前得克萨斯州参议员候选人，贝托·奥罗克。希肯卢珀，约翰·希肯卢珀，前科罗拉多州州长——我花了好长时间才读完关于这些人的资料。我花了一整天时间才弄清楚谁是谁。是的。
Thank you for that. We flew in. We went to four things in a day. First, Knoxville, Iowa. Weigel looks kind of like a reporter from the '70s-- mustached, notably, casually dressed, hair askew. We're going to this tiny event at this tiny brewpub. And as we're driving up to it, we think we see the candidate standing right outside.
谢谢你。我们飞了过来。我们一天参加了四场活动。首先是爱荷华州的诺克斯维尔。维格尔看起来有点像70年代的记者——留着胡子，穿着随便，头发蓬乱。我们要去一家小酒吧参加一场小型活动。当我们开车过去时，我们以为看到候选人正站在外面。
It does look like Beto. You're right.
那看起来确实是贝托。你是对的。
That guy?
那个人？
Yeah.
是的。
I think it's him.
我觉得是他。
He's fairly tall. Huh. That's the outfit, the chinos and everything. That is him. Isn't it surreal? Just like when you're walking through a small town, you're like, oh, that guy running for president. Yeah, all right.
他挺高的。呵。那身行头，卡其裤什么的。那是他。这不是很超现实吗？就像当你走在小镇上，你会想，哦，那个正在竞选总统的人。是的，好吧。
I don't know why it's surreal to him. This happens to him literally all the time.
我不知道为什么对他来说这很超现实。这种事对他来说简直是家常便饭。
I think he's waiting to be introduced. Oh, Amy. That's his wife, who's with him today-- the one woman in the--
我想他是在等被介绍。哦，艾米。那是他今天和他一起的妻子——那个女人在——
In that group?
在那群人里？
Yeah. [CHUCKLES]
是的。[轻笑]
What?
什么？
I don't know. Just, it's fun living through things like this.
不知道。只是，经历这样的事情很有趣。
Oh, he's really into it.
哦，他真的很投入。
It thrills him. He loves this. There's this one moment after Beto finishes his little talk, and people come up to him and ask questions. And this guy-- it's in this tiny brewery, which kind of looks like a rec room, almost. And this one voter walks up to Beto with a beer in his hand, just like as though he's at some kind of relaxed Friday afternoon cocktail party. And Weigel sees this, and jumps up and kind of elbows people out of the way.
这让他感到兴奋。他喜欢这样。有一次，在贝托结束演讲后，人们上来问他问题。那个家伙——就在这个小酿酒厂里，看起来几乎像个休息室。这个选民拿着啤酒走到贝托面前，就像在周五下午的鸡尾酒会上一样轻松。维格尔看到了这一点，跳起来，把人们挤到一边。
Sorry, I'm just trying to get a picture of the guy holding the beer while talking to him, just because it amuses me.
抱歉，我只是想给那个拿着啤酒和他在说话的人拍张照，因为这让我觉得很有趣。
Oh. Yeah, sure.
哦。好的，没问题。
It kind of exemplifies the special part we're in, in the election. There's no Secret Service. There are no real barriers. Anyone can just wander up to a presidential candidate. It's extremely intimate. It's his favorite time of the presidential elections. People are really close to each other. At one point at another event, two of the candidates, Tim Ryan and Jay Inslee, they ran right past each other.
这在某种程度上体现了我们目前所处的选举阶段。没有特勤局，没有真正的障碍。任何人都可以随意走到总统候选人面前。这非常亲密。这是他最喜欢的总统选举时刻。人们彼此之间非常亲近。有一次在另一场活动中，两位候选人，蒂姆·瑞安和杰伊·英斯利，他们刚好跑过彼此。
You're back in the district.
你回到选区了。
Go get them, Congressman Ryan!
加油，瑞安众议员！
You did a great job, Governor! I love your speech!
你做得太棒了，州长！我喜欢你的演讲！
You're awesome!
你太棒了！
Do it again! I want to hear it one more time.
再来一次！我想再听一遍。
It's almost like Weigel and the candidates are on some kind of a cruise or at a camp together. And they just bump into each other day after day, like, oh, hi again. Oh, I'll see you tomorrow. Oh, I'll see you later. Are you going to be at the pizza thing?
感觉就像维格尔和这些候选人都在游轮上或者是营地里。他们日复一日地相遇，就像，哦，又见面了。哦，明天见。哦，稍后见。你要去吃披萨吗？
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thanks a lot. Good to see you again.
非常感谢。很高兴再次见到你。
Yeah. Good to see you.
是的。很高兴见到你。
See you at the-- I will not catch up with you in the run. But I'll--
回头见——我不会在竞选路上追上你的。但我会——
Are you going to run it?
你要参选吗？
You also, in this phase of things, you get to see the candidates interacting in the world, the regular world.
在这个阶段，你还可以看到候选人在现实世界中互动。
Right.
没错。
Regular people with just the most random stuff that you wouldn't normally see.
普通人会遇到你平时看不到的随机事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I had this thing happened to me. I was checking into our hotel in Waterloo, Iowa, right?
我遇到过这件事。我在爱荷华州滑铁卢的酒店办理入住，对吧？
What kind of hotel?
什么样的酒店？
Hampton Inn.
汉普顿酒店。
OK.
好的。
And the girl who's checking us in, who's like 20-ish maybe-- she seems funny and smiley. And she's really surprised to see these reporters there. And it turns out she's never heard of the Iowa caucuses. Even though the state is crawling with these candidates, it's totally possible to lead your life and miss it. So Weigel explains it to her.
负责办理入住的女孩，看起来大概20岁出头——她看起来很有趣，脸上带着笑容。看到这些记者在那里，她感到非常惊讶。结果她从来没听说过爱荷华州党团会议。尽管这个州到处都是这些候选人，但完全有可能过着自己的生活却错过了这一切。所以维格尔向她解释了。
Yeah, instead of a presidential primary here--
是的，代替这里的总统初选——
All these presidential candidates for the nation to vote, blah, blah, blah. We go upstairs. But my key is demagnetized, so I go back downstairs. I leave all my stuff, including the recorder, there. And when I get downstairs, I see Beto just standing there. And he's trying to get a free bottle of water from the girl. And I'm like, Beto?
所有这些国家总统候选人都在投票，等等。我们上楼了。但我的房卡消磁了，所以我又回到了楼下。我把所有东西，包括录音机，都留在了那里。当我下楼时，我看到贝托正站在那儿。他正试图从那个女孩那里免费要一瓶水。我当时就想，贝托？
Wait, do you know him?
等等，你认识他吗？
No.
不认识。
You've never met him.
你从来没见过他。
No. And I say to him, Beto, tell her what you're doing here in Iowa. And she looks at him, and she goes, are you running for president, in this totally sarcastic way. Like of course you're not. And he goes, actually, yes, I am, which is just a weird answer to that question. And she jumps up, goes, yes, queen! And he's like totally taken aback and is like, thank you so much. And she goes, I hope you win the presidency-- like not very sincere.
没有。我对他说，贝托，告诉她你在这儿爱荷华州干什么。她看着他，讽刺地说，你在竞选总统吗？就好像他当然不是。他说，实际上，是的，我确实是，这对他那个问题的回答太奇怪了。她跳起来说，是的，女王！他完全被吓到了，说，非常感谢。她说，我希望你赢得总统大选——听起来不太真诚。
And so this is just the world that Weigel was marinating in.
这就是维格尔所处的环境。
He knows them all so thoroughly at this point. He knows them as thoroughly as he knows the gas stations in Iowa. We were at a bar. He starts talking about the jokes that candidates tell when they're out on [INAUDIBLE].
此时此刻，他非常了解他们所有人。他了解他们就像了解爱荷华州的加油站一样彻底。我们在一家酒吧。他开始谈论候选人在外面时讲的笑话。
The horrible spouse joke. Whereas, Warren has a riff where she talks about dropping out of school. It's like, fell in love. Woo-hoo. Got married, Woo-hoo. Had a baby. Woo. And she just-- it's like a Simpsons joke, almost. She imitates getting less and less excited about her bad life decisions. She's like, and then I met my first husband. Never a good idea when you have to number them, things like that.
糟糕的配偶笑话。而沃伦有一个即兴表演，她谈论辍学。就像，坠入爱河。呜呼。结婚了，呜呼。生了个孩子。呜。然后她只是——就像辛普森一家的笑话一样。她模仿自己对糟糕的人生决定越来越不兴奋的样子。她说，然后我遇到了我的第一任丈夫。当你必须给他们编号时，这从来都不是个好主意，诸如此类。
My favorite Klobuchar joke is, she talks about how she's Slovenian American. And it's like, and for years, I was the most famous Slovenian American in politics. But then Melania Trump arrived, and you know what? It's like looking in a mirror. You laugh. It's like a [INAUDIBLE]. But Biden does the, my wife is always right joke. Who else does that? People mostly learn to not do that.
我最喜欢的克洛布查笑话是，她谈论自己是斯洛文尼亚裔美国人。她说，多年来，我是政界最著名的斯洛文尼亚裔美国人。但后来梅拉尼娅·特朗普来了，你知道吗？这就像照镜子。你笑了起来。这就像一个[听不清]。但拜登讲那个“我妻子永远是对的”的笑话。还有谁讲那个？人们大多学会了不那样做。
For today on our program, we're in this unusual political moment. The Democrats have even more people running for president than the Republicans did last time. 25 people-- what is that?
在今天的节目中，我们正处于一个不同寻常的政治时刻。民主党参选总统的人数甚至比共和党上次还要多。25个人——那是什么情况？
Today in our show, we are not going to cover all 25. What we're going to do is we're going to drop in here and there. My sense is that, at this point, everyone is still getting to know who these people are. And so hopefully, you will get in close with some of them and get an impression of them.
在今天的节目中，我们不会涵盖所有25个人。我们要做的就是四处走走。我觉得，在这一点上，每个人还在了解这些人是谁。所以希望你能近距离观察他们中的一些人，并对他们有所了解。
And what we're especially interested in in this show is all of the candidates at the bottom. That's the story of this particular moment in the election, is all those people between 0% and 1% in the polls who might still have a chance trying to get noticed and break out of the pack, and join the front runners, which is just an enormously difficult thing to do. And it's just right now starting to shift. How do you get noticed and rise above 1% in this pack of 25? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在这个节目中，我们特别感兴趣的是底层的所有候选人。这是这次选举特殊时刻的故事，是那些在民调中处于0%到1%之间的人，他们可能还有机会努力被注意到，从人群中脱颖而出，加入领跑者的行列，这是一件极其困难的事情。目前局势才刚刚开始转变。在这25人的队伍中，你如何引起注意并升至1%以上？来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1.
第一幕。
No. No acts today. Let's just drive around.
不。今天没有表演。我们开车兜兜风吧。
So bossy. All right, ma'am. So Zoe, so 25 candidates-- and this political operative explained this to me, and I found it a helpful way to look at this. He said that the best way to picture what is happening right now is that there are four front runners-- Joe Biden, Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth Warren, and Kamala Harris. And then depending on how you count it, Pete Buttigieg is in there, too.
真霸道。好吧，女士。那么佐伊，25位候选人——这位政治运作人员向我解释过，我觉得这是一种很有帮助的看待方式。他说，描述现在发生的事情最好的方式是，有四位领跑者——乔·拜登、伯尼·桑德斯、伊丽莎白·沃伦和卡玛拉·哈里斯。然后根据你的计算方式，皮特·布蒂吉格也在其中。
Their poll numbers are way higher than anybody else. And also, they get most of the donations and most of the press attention, which then generates more donations and more press attention in a kind of self-perpetuating cycle that sucks the air out that all the others want to breathe.
他们的民调数字远高于其他人。此外，他们还获得了大部分捐款和媒体关注，这又产生更多的捐款和媒体关注，形成一种自我强化的循环，吸干了其他人想要呼吸的空气。
So that's them. And then below those four or five people, there's basically everyone else in the pack of 25, most of them struggling to break 1%. And it seems just very interesting what is happening with them. And so, Zoe, you watched them trying to figure that out.
所以那是他们。然后在这四五个人之下，基本上就是25人队伍中的其他人，他们中的大多数都在努力突破1%。而且目前发生在他们身上的事情看起来非常有趣。所以，佐伊，你看着他们试图弄清楚这一点。
OK. So for example, take John Hickenlooper.
好的。比如，以约翰·希肯卢珀为例。
Former governor of Colorado.
科罗拉多州前州长。
His polling is now at less than 1%. If you haven't heard of him, that's probably why. He cannot draw a crowd by himself. If he put out a sign in Iowa today, Hickenlooper Speaks, Please RSVP, probably nobody would come to that event.
他的民调现在不到1%。如果你没听说过他，这就是原因。他自己一个人无法吸引人群。如果他今天在爱荷华州挂出一块牌子，上面写着“希肯卢珀演讲，请回复”，可能根本没人会来参加那场活动。
Crickets, right? Yeah. OK.
鸦雀无声，对吧？是的。好的。
Yeah. So he does these-- they're called retail stops, when a politician tours a factory or whatever. So right now, we're at this brand new distillery in Des Moines, me and Dave Weigel.
是的。所以他做这些——他们被称为零售站点，也就是政治家参观工厂之类的地方。所以现在，我们正在得梅因一家全新的酿酒厂，我和戴夫·维格尔在一起。
--because this stuff is actually kind of fun to watch.
——因为看这些东西实际上挺有趣的。
And we walk in. Hickenlooper and this one elderly Iowa voter are sitting at the bar, the brand new bar in the brand new distillery. It's a totally staged photo op. There are about 20 reporters in a semicircle around them. But obviously, if you look through the camera lens, it looks like it's just Hickenlooper and the voter.
我们走了进去。希肯卢珀和一位年迈的爱荷华州选民正坐在酒吧里，那是全新酿酒厂里的全新酒吧。这完全是摆拍的摄影机会。周围大约有20名记者围成一个半圆。但很显然，如果你通过镜头看，看起来就像只有希肯卢珀和那位选民。
What a pleasure. I can't tell you. This is an absolute honor.
真是荣幸。我无法形容。这绝对是一种荣誉。
You're running for what?
你在竞选什么？
The old guy's like, you're running for what?
那位老人说，你在竞选什么？
The highest office of the land-- President of the United States.
国家的最高职位——美国总统。
Oh, really? OK.
哦，真的吗？好吧。
So I was an entrepreneur. I built brew pubs all over the-- mostly over the Midwest. But I built the biggest brew pub in the country, and Denver was my first one. Always in abandoned warehouses. I won the Award of Honor from the National Trust for Historic Preservation. I don't know what that's good for.
我曾是一名企业家。我在整个——主要是在中西部——建造了酿酒厂。但我建造了全国最大的酿酒厂，丹佛是我的第一个。总是在废弃的仓库里。我获得了国家历史保护信托基金的荣誉奖。我不知道那有什么用。
It's so strange that these guys actually-- they do have to kind of just brag about themselves to people, huh?
这些家伙实际上不得不向人们吹嘘自己，真是太奇怪了，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Like people don't know who they are. I mean, not to be mean about it, but people [INAUDIBLE] don't know who they are. So they just have to say, here's all the stuff I've done.
就像人们不知道他们是谁一样。我的意思是，不是要针对他们，但人们[听不清]不知道他们是谁。所以他们只能说，这是我做过的所有事情。
Even he gets kind of self-conscious about it.
连他自己都对此感到有点尴尬。
I call it the fundamental nonsense of Washington, or place of common sense. That's my shtick. But anyway--
我称之为华盛顿的基本废话，或者常识之地。那是我的拿手好戏。但无论如何——
That's my shtick?
那是我的拿手好戏？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, I like that.
哦，我喜欢这个。
Good luck.
祝你好运。
Good luck, the old guy says to him. 20 people are recording this, and no one is going to use any of this. No one's going to use these quotes, right? We move on to a distillery tour. Hickenlooper has tons of opinions about that. Remember, he was in this business.
祝你好运，老人对他说。20个人正在录制这一幕，没人会用这段内容。没人会用这些引语，对吧？我们继续进行酿酒厂参观。希肯卢珀对此有很多意见。记住，他以前是干这一行的。
I always call it the Haagen-Dazs effect, which is--
我总是称之为哈根达斯效应，也就是——
No one is going to use any of this either. Instead, the reporters just wait til the end. They gather around, they ask him questions about Trump. That stuff, they might use.
也没人会用这段。相反，记者们只是等到最后。他们围过来，问他关于特朗普的问题。那些东西，他们可能会用。
So this whole thing, this whole tour, all of it is just for pictures.
所以整件事，整个行程，全部都是为了拍照。
Yeah. What the campaign hopes for is that, out of the 25 candidates, tonight viewers will see a picture somewhere of John Hickenlooper drinking a beer in Iowa.
是的。竞选团队希望的是，在25位候选人中，今晚观众会在某处看到一张约翰·希肯卢珀在爱荷华州喝啤酒的照片。
I don't see how that's going to make him president. That is not going to be enough to take him out of the 1% and put him up there with the front runners.
我不明白这怎么能让他成为总统。那不足以让他摆脱1%，并让他与领跑者并驾齐驱。
Iowa, though-- voter by voter. These 1%-ers, they're also going around Iowa talking, and talking, and talking to the actual voters, the real human beings who go to the caucuses and vote. And in order to do that, the candidates who can't draw a crowd on their own, one thing those guys do is go to local Democratic clubs. The idea is you do these Democratic clubs for a while, county Democratic clubs, and then you get popular enough to graduate out and draw a crowd on your own.
不过，爱荷华州——选民逐个击破。这些1%的人，他们也正在爱荷华州到处走动，与实际选民、参加党团会议并投票的真正人类交谈、交谈再交谈。为了做到这一点，那些无法独立吸引人群的候选人，他们做的一件事就是去当地的民主党俱乐部。他们的想法是，你先去这些民主党俱乐部一段时间，比如县民主党俱乐部，然后你就会变得足够受欢迎，从而脱颖而出并独立吸引人群。
Ah.
啊。
Like Pete Buttigieg, he had to do the Democratic clubs for about a month. He went around introducing himself, and then he graduated out. Now he can draw a crowd on his own. Most of them have not.
就像皮特·布蒂吉格，他不得不参加了大约一个月的民主党俱乐部活动。他四处介绍自己，然后他脱颖而出。现在他可以独立吸引人群了。他们中的大多数还没有做到。
I remember-- there's a Delaney bumper sticker. They're real.
我记得——有一个德莱尼的保险杠贴纸。它们是真的。
Whoa.
哇。
There was one that was--
有一个是——
What if that's Delaney's car, though?
如果那是德莱尼的车呢？
It could be.
有可能。
John Delaney, also at less than 1%, rich guy and former congressman from Maryland. He's doing a meet-and-greet with the Clive County Democrats at Wobbly Boots Barbecue.
约翰·德莱尼，支持率也低于1%，是有钱人，来自马里兰州的前众议员。他正在沃布里靴子烧烤店与克莱夫县民主党人进行见面会。
So I'm sure this is going to surprise you. I actually believe I have the best [INAUDIBLE].
所以我敢肯定这会让你感到惊讶。我实际上相信我有最好的[听不清]。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I think what makes it best is it's different, and I can get it done.
但我认为最棒的是它是不同的，我可以完成它。
Delaney's moderate. He's not into Medicare for All. He's not into the Green New Deal. Even his climate change plan is all wrapped up in red, white, and blue bunting.
德莱尼是个温和派。他不赞成“全民医保”。他不赞成“绿色新政”。即使他的气候变化计划也包裹在红白蓝三色旗中。
Because we're solving the problem the old-fashioned American way by inventing and building.
因为我们正在以老式的美国方式通过发明和建造来解决这个问题。
Hear hear!
说得好！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The room is packed, actually. People here are eating John Delaney up.
事实上，房间挤满了人。这里的人很吃约翰·德莱尼那一套。
So it's working.
所以这奏效了。
Yeah. I came to see exactly this, one of these 1%-ers winning people over to their side. And Delaney is betting his chips on Iowa. He's got eight offices there. That's more than anyone else, as of a couple weeks ago, anyway. He's been there the most times.
是的。我来这里就是为了看这个，看其中一个1%的人如何赢得人们的支持。德莱尼把筹码压在了爱荷华州。他在那里有八个办事处。至少在几周前，这是人数最多的。他去那里的次数最多。
We ran into him in the airport on the way there. It was his 29th trip. He's doing the purist version of this play on the campaign trail, a Jimmy Carter play. It's basically get a huge surge by doing great in the Iowa caucuses, the first in the nation. And the way you do that is voter by voter. That's what he's doing out here.
我们在去那里的路上在机场遇到了他。这是他的第29次行程。他正在竞选活动中进行这种玩法的纯粹版本，吉米·卡特的玩法。基本上是通过在全国第一个爱荷华州党团会议上表现出色来获得巨大的激增。而你做到这一点的方法就是逐个击破选民。他正在这里做这件事。
That's what Carter did. Carter was the first candidate who ever did that. They didn't have a caucus before, or they didn't have a caucus people paid attention to before. He lived here. Came in famously second to uncommitted. It was like uncommitted, 30, Carter, 25 or something. And people were like, oh, he beat all the much more famous senators. Who is this guy? So that was more than 40 years ago. But it's still like--
那就是卡特做的事情。卡特是第一个那样做的候选人。他们以前没有党团会议，或者他们没有关注党团会议。他住在这里。著名地排在“不承诺”之后。就像“不承诺”30%，卡特25%之类的。人们当时就想，哦，他击败了所有更著名的参议员。这个家伙是谁？那已经是40多年前的事了。但它仍然像——
So everybody's doing this Carter play. That's how you could think about it.
所以每个人都在玩这个卡特游戏。这就是你可以考虑的方式。
A lot of them.
他们中的许多人。
I talked to one voter. He liked this meeting so much, he said he might caucus for Delaney. He might. He's still shopping around. But the number of people shopping has dropped since the first debate. And the window's closing for the 1%-ers.
我和一位选民谈过。他非常喜欢这次会议，他说他可能会在党团会议上投票给德莱尼。他可能会。他还在货比三家。但自第一次辩论以来，货比三家的人数有所下降。对于这些1%的人来说，机会之窗正在关闭。
The debates-- they are probably the biggest chance that any of these underdogs get to rise out of the underdog pack and come barking to the forefront.
辩论——这可能是任何这些弱势群体候选人从弱势群体中崛起并发出声音来到前台的最大机会。
The next one's at the end of the month. There has been one so far, of course.
下一次在月底。当然，目前已经进行了一次。
And two days before the first debate, the team for one of the candidates, as you know, Zoe, let me watch a full day of debate prep. And by sheer luck, it was the candidate that most of the media declared the breakout star of the first night of the debate, Julián Castro. Zoe, you ready to hear the story?
在第一次辩论前两天，其中一位候选人的团队，正如你所知，佐伊，让我看了一整天的辩论准备。碰巧，这位候选人就是大多数媒体宣布的辩论第一晚的黑马，胡利安·卡斯特罗。佐伊，你准备好听这个故事了吗？
Obviously.
当然。
OK. Here is the team that got him to victory.
好的。这就是带领他走向胜利的团队。
OK, so the three of you, have you ever done debate prep before?
好的，你们三个，你们以前做过辩论准备吗？
Nope.
没有。
No.
Meet Maya Rupert, Jen Fiore, and Sawyer Hackett, the campaign manager, communications advisor, and national press secretary for Julián Castro. Castro was mayor of San Antonio, then ran the Department of Housing and Urban Development under President Obama. They all worked for Castro there. If you add it up, they had done three full days of debate prep before this one, the one that I saw. And they were going to do one more after that. That is how important this is to them.
来见见玛雅·鲁珀特、詹·菲奥里和索耶·哈克特，他们分别是胡利安·卡斯特罗的竞选经理、传播顾问和全国新闻秘书。卡斯特罗曾任圣安东尼奥市市长，后来在奥巴马总统领导下管理住房和城市发展部。他们都在那里为卡斯特罗工作。如果你算一下，他们在这次辩论之前已经进行了三整天的辩论准备，就是我看到的那次。之后他们还要再做一次。这对他们来说有多重要。
All right, so this is what we've got on the agenda for this morning.
好的，这就是我们今天早上议程上的内容。
We're in a hotel conference room in Miami. All over the walls are these big pages torn from flip charts, each with a different topic and then three or four possible talking points for the candidate to use in the debate that they worked out in previous sessions. The guy talking is deputy campaign manager, Derek Eadon, who is running these sessions. And he's up in front by the easel with the flip chart.
我们在迈阿密的酒店会议室。墙上到处都是从翻页挂图上撕下来的大纸张，每一张都有不同的主题，然后有三到四个可能的谈话要点供候选人在辩论中使用，这些都是他们在之前的会议中确定的。正在说话的是副竞选经理德里克·伊顿，他负责这些会议。他站在画架旁的翻页挂图前。
And the candidate is standing at one of five podiums in front of the room. He's in jeans and a white dress shirt, sleeves rolled up, immaculately clean, white Adidas, iced tea, which, by the way, he told the New York Times is his comfort food on the road.
候选人站在房间前的五个讲台之一处。他穿着牛仔裤和白色礼服衬衫，袖子卷起来，一尘不染，穿着白色阿迪达斯，喝着冰茶，顺便说一下，他告诉《纽约时报》，这是他在路上的慰藉食物。
And then we want to talk through a little bit of closing statement.
然后我们要讨论一点结束语。
Castro's staff, I should say, is deeply aware that most voters still do not know who Julián Castro is. And they told me that success in the first debate, to them, would be something very basic-- that voters would notice Castro, that he's in the race. Here's Jen Fiore, his senior communications advisor.
我应该说，卡斯特罗的员工非常清楚，大多数选民仍然不知道胡利安·卡斯特罗是谁。他们告诉我，他们认为第一次辩论的成功将是非常基本的——选民会注意到卡斯特罗，他正在竞选中。这是他的高级传播顾问詹·菲奥里的说法。
Maybe it changes their math, right? Maybe they were supporting one person. They thought, oh, but wait. But wait. I heard a lot of interesting stuff from Julián Castro, and I've got to shift my math.
也许这改变了他们的想法，对吧？也许他们支持某个人。他们心想，哦，但是等等。但是等等。我从胡利安·卡斯特罗那里听到了很多有趣的事情，我必须改变我的想法。
One of the flip charts on the wall was, "Top Five Takeaways," meaning the top five things that they want voters to take away from this debate. They read, "I like him," "he won," "game changer," "can handle his own," and "win/beat Trump."
墙上的翻页挂图之一是“前五大收获”，意思是他们希望选民从这次辩论中获得的前五件事。上面写着：“我喜欢他”、“他赢了”、“游戏规则改变者”、“能独当一面”和“赢/打败特朗普”。
So OK. How do you get voters to change the math? If you think about it, the debate means 10 candidates standing on stage for 120 minutes, two hours. So that's 10 minutes per candidate. But you take away commercial breaks and questions. What it leaves, the average talking time for each candidate is actually eight minutes-- eight minutes to implant yourselves into the brains of millions of people. Eight minutes-- though that is just the average. Not everybody gets that much, which is actually the thing that Castro is most afraid of going into the debate. He says they've studied these moderators.
好的。你怎么让选民改变想法？如果你想一想，辩论意味着10位候选人站在台上120分钟，两个小时。所以每位候选人有10分钟。但除去广告时间和提问。剩下的，每位候选人的平均谈话时间实际上是8分钟——8分钟，将你们自己植入数百万人的大脑中。8分钟——虽然那只是平均值。不是每个人都能得到那么多，这实际上是卡斯特罗在辩论前最担心的事情。他说他们研究了这些主持人。
And they don't have a track record of actually enforcing time very well. So you've got to be mindful. OK, if they're going to let people go, the worst case scenario is not that I am flat, it's that I don't get any time, whatsoever. Because people got into a skirmish, and other people butted in. And all of a sudden, the time's gone.
他们并没有很好地执行时间的记录。所以你必须小心。好的，如果他们要让人们继续说，最坏的情况不是我表现平平，而是我根本没得到任何时间。因为人们陷入了争吵，其他人插话了。突然间，时间没了。
Some candidates just end up getting five minutes. So you have limited time, and you have no idea what they're going to ask you about. And so you have to prepare perfect, pithy answers for every imaginable question. And what perfect means-- Julián's staff wants him to work three specific elements into each of those answers if he can.
有些候选人最终只能得到五分钟。所以你的时间有限，而且你根本不知道他们会问你什么。所以你必须为每一个可以想象的问题准备完美、简练的答案。什么是完美——胡利安的员工希望他如果可以的话，在每一个答案中加入三个具体要素。
They want some of his personal story-- raised by a single mother, working class neighborhood, that kind of thing. They want him to talk about the stuff that he has done in previous jobs in government-- prove that he's capable. And of course, they want him to talk about what he's going to do next if he gets the job of president. All three things in each answer. So for instance, when they're hammering out an answer about climate and the Green New Deal, Castro, he starts pitching policy ideas.
他们想要他个人故事的一些内容——由单亲妈妈抚养长大，工人阶级社区，诸如此类。他们想要他谈论他在之前政府工作中做过的事情——证明他有能力。当然，他们想要他谈论如果他得到总统这份工作，他下一步要做什么。每个答案中都有这三件事。所以例如，当他们在敲定关于气候和绿色新政的答案时，卡斯特罗，他开始推销政策想法。
I think here, we want to stress-- we're going to lead on combating climate change, get to net zero, create jobs in the new energy--
我想在这里，我们要强调——我们将引领应对气候变化，实现净零排放，在新能源领域创造就业——
Then Jen jumps in. Talk more about your experience.
然后詹插话了。多谈谈你的经验。
Right, but not a lot of an impact. Maybe nobody on the stage, other than maybe Governor Inslee, has actually done the work to help people recover the way that you have, right, as HUD secretary. I remember the trip that you took to Louisiana after that horrendous flood, and--
对，但没有太大的影响。可能台上除了英斯利州长之外，没有人真正像你作为住房部长那样做过帮助人们恢复的工作，对吧？我记得你在那场可怕的洪水后去路易斯安那州的旅行，而且——
Talk about what you've done on climate change, she urges him, which he then incorporates into his next run-through of the answer.
谈谈你在气候变化方面所做的事情，她敦促他，然后他将此整合到他接下来的答案重演中。
As Housing Secretary, I worked to make sure that communities could rebuild from natural disasters in a more sustainable way. And as president, the first thing that I would do--
作为住房部长，我致力于确保社区能以更可持续的方式从自然灾害中重建。而作为总统，我做的第一件事就是——
Notice the pivot there from his previous experience to his plans for the future? What makes all this so tricky is that under the rules of the debate, he has to finish his answer in just 60 seconds. To figure out how to fit everything in, basically, Castro answers the same question over--
注意从他过去的经验到他未来计划的过渡了吗？让这一切如此棘手的是，根据辩论规则，他必须在60秒内完成回答。为了找出如何塞进所有内容，基本上，卡斯特罗一次又一次地回答同一个问题——
I grew up with a grandmother that had diabetes.
我是在一个有糖尿病的祖母身边长大的。
--and over--
——一次又——
I grew up with a grandmother who had diabetes.
我是在一个有糖尿病的祖母身边长大的。
--and over--
——一次又——
I grew up with a grandmother who had diabetes.
我是在一个有糖尿病的祖母身边长大的。
--and over.
——一次又。
You know, I grew up with a grandmother who had diabetes.
你知道，我是在一个有糖尿病的祖母身边长大的。
In case it isn't clear, each of those times, he talks until he reaches one minute.
如果还不清楚，每一次，他都谈到一分钟为止。
And this distinction between physical health care and mental health care.
以及身体健康护理和心理健康护理之间的这种区别。
[TIMER BEEPS]
[计时器哔声]
So was that a minute, or was it mistimed? That seemed like a forever minute. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
所以那是一分钟，还是时间算错了？那似乎是永恒的一分钟。[笑声]是的。
They spend hours doing this. It's tedium chewing over how to best fill those precious eight minutes they're going to get. And of course, the one politician that it's hard to picture doing this is the public speaker who improvises his way through stadium speeches and meet-and-greets at the Korean Demilitarized Zone-- the guy who got his job specifically by not doing this and is beloved by lots of people for not talking like this, the man that Castro hopes is going to be facing off against next year-- Donald Trump.
他们花了好几个小时做这件事。咀嚼如何最好地填满他们将要得到的宝贵八分钟是乏味的。当然，最难想象做这件事的一位政治家是那个在体育场演讲和在韩国非军事区见面会上即兴演讲的演说家——那个通过不这样做而得到这份工作，并因不这样说话而被很多人喜爱的人，那个卡斯特罗希望明年能面对的人——唐纳德·特朗普。
To break things up during the day, the staff organizes a surprise for Castro, just a little breather to lighten things up. Derek gets out his phone, and people crowd around him.
为了在一天的过程中休息一下，员工为卡斯特罗组织了一个惊喜，只是为了放松一下的小休息。德里克拿出他的手机，人们围了过来。
Hello.
你好。
Can you see?
你能看到吗？
We can't see just yet.
我们还看不到。
It's a call with the Sklar brothers, the comedians and actors, Jason and Randy Sklar, who like Castro. And they've decided that they wanted to pitch jokes for him to use during the debate. The campaign was like, sure, why not?
这是一次与斯克拉兄弟的通话，他们是喜欢卡斯特罗的喜剧演员和演员，杰森和兰迪·斯克拉。他们决定想要为他在辩论中使用提供笑话。竞选团队心想，当然，为什么不呢？
There we go.
好了。
All right.
There we go. How are you doing?
好了。你们怎么样？
We're good, man. How are you?
我们很好，伙计。你们呢？
That's good. Come take a seat. We've got Secretary Castro right here. We're in the middle--
很好。来坐下。我们有卡斯特罗部长在这里。我们正在——
Castro met the Sklar brothers when they had him on their podcast. The Sklars are identical twins. And important fact about Julián Castro-- he has an identical twin brother, who's also in politics-- Congressman Joaquin Castro.
卡斯特罗在他们的播客上见过斯克拉兄弟。斯克拉兄弟是同卵双胞胎。关于胡利安·卡斯特罗的一个重要事实是——他有一个同卵双胞胎兄弟，他也在从政——众议员华金·卡斯特罗。
You were great on our podcast. Thank you so much.
你在我们的播客上表现得很棒。非常感谢。
Hey, thanks a lot.
嘿，非常感谢。
And we were thinking about things that you can either take or leave, but it's just thoughts in our brain that you put into your own speak. And so, OK. So do you want to hear what we have so far?
我们正在思考你可以采纳或忽略的事情，但这只是我们大脑中的想法，你可以用你自己的话来说。所以，好的。你想听听我们目前有什么吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Go ahead. I'm getting a pad and paper down right here.
好的，好的，好的。说吧。我正准备在这里拿个本子和笔。
This is just a general one. Some folks in this race are against Medicare. I'm for Medicare not only because I think it has value, but also out of respect for some of my older opponents, like Bernie and Biden.
这是一个很一般的。这次竞选中的一些人反对医保。我支持医保不仅是因为我认为它有价值，还因为出于对我一些年长对手的尊重，比如伯尼和拜登。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's so true.
太真实了。
They're going to need it. They're going to need it now.
他们会需要它的。他们现在就会需要它。
Hard to imagine a more receptive room for that joke, just [INAUDIBLE] at the time with the front runners in the race. Here's another.
很难想象还有比这更能接受那个笑话的房间了，只是在与竞选中的领跑者们在一起时[听不清]。还有另一个。
There are more people on this debate stage than at a Trump inauguration.
在这个辩论台上的人比特朗普就职典礼上的人还多。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, like there's a lot of people up here. I mean, the height-- how tall are you? You're our height.
是的，这里确实有很多人。我的意思是，身高——你有多高？你是我们的身高。
Yeah, 5' 7" or 5' 8". Yeah.
是的，5英尺7英寸或5英尺8英寸。是的。
OK, 5' 7", 5' 8". So you're our height. So you're standing next to Cory Booker, who's like 6' 2".
好的，5英尺7英寸，5英尺8英寸。所以你是我们的身高。所以你站在科里·布克旁边，他有6英尺2英寸。
6' 2", yeah.
6英尺2英寸，是的。
[INAUDIBLE] is 6' 4", and de Blasio is 6' 5". So you can say, now I'm standing up here, you can see that I'm not as tall as these guys. But I went to Trump's doctor-- I went to Trump's doctor, and he said I was 6 foot 3.
[听不清]是6英尺4英寸，德布拉西奥是6英尺5英寸。所以你可以说，现在我站在这里，你可以看到我不像这些家伙那么高。但我去了特朗普的医生那里——我去了特朗普的医生那里，他说我有6英尺3英寸。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The Sklars went through jokes, all of them pretty mean, about candidates Booker, de Blasio, Ryan, Moulton, Klobuchar, and Inslee. And can I just say, respect for anybody who can make a joke about Moulton, Ryan, or Inslee? None of these jokes are going to make the cut, Castro's staff tells me later. Those kinds of jokes just aren't Castro's style. The one joke they could imagine the candidate actually telling onstage at the debate-- I have to say, it really surprised me-- the one about how he's kind of short.
斯克拉兄弟讲了一堆笑话，所有这些关于布克、德布拉西奥、瑞安、莫尔顿、克洛布查和英斯利候选人的笑话都相当刻薄。我能说吗，尊重任何能拿莫尔顿、瑞安或英斯利开玩笑的人？卡斯特罗的员工后来告诉我，这些笑话一个都不会被采用。那种笑话根本不是卡斯特罗的风格。他们能想象候选人真正会在辩论台上讲的那一个笑话——我不得不说，这真的让我很惊讶——关于他个子有点矮的那一个。
Of course, the other thing that Julián has to practice is reacting to all the other candidates and the moderators. They study videos of his opponents, and they do this.
当然，胡利安必须练习的另一件事是对所有其他候选人和主持人的反应。他们研究对手的视频，并这样做。
Hello, and welcome to sunny Miami, Florida, for the first Democratic debate of the 2020 presidential cycle. I'm Rachel Maddow.
你好，欢迎来到阳光明媚的迈阿密，佛罗里达州，参加2020年总统周期的第一次民主党辩论。我是瑞秋·马多。
I'm a lot of people.
我是很多人。
It's a mock debate session. Sawyer and a staffer named Millie play the moderators. Four other staffers stand at podiums flanking Castro's. The men are now in ties and jackets. They want to give Castro the chance to run his answers under debate conditions where he's going to have to wait for his opponents to speak, where he might have to field answers that kind of poke at him.
这是一个模拟辩论环节。索耶和一个名叫米莉的员工扮演主持人。另外四名员工站在卡斯特罗两侧的讲台上。男人们现在打着领带，穿着夹克。他们想给卡斯特罗一个机会，在辩论条件下进行回答，他将不得不等待对手发言，他可能不得不应付那种有点挑衅他的回答。
And I have to say, it was totally charming and fascinating how accurate they tried to be at playing the other candidates in the debate. Out on the road, they've watched these politicians deliver the same lines again and again. So when Derek, who is playing Cory Booker, gets a question about gun violence, he has Booker's lines down cold.
我不得不说，他们试图表现得准确地扮演辩论中的其他候选人是非常迷人且令人着迷的。在路上，他们看了这些政治家一遍又一遍地重复同样的台词。所以当德里克，扮演科里·布克时，被问及关于枪支暴力的问题，他把布克的台词背得滚瓜烂熟。
I've been waking up in the middle of the night hearing gunshot. I released my policy not far from where Shahad Smith had been killed.
我半夜醒来能听到枪声。我在离沙哈德·史密斯被杀地点不远的地方发布了我的政策。
When a staffer playing Beto O'Rourke is asked about Castro's ability to connect with Latinos and to speak Spanish-- apparently, Castro is not as good at Spanish as Beto is-- fake Beto responds fully in character.
当扮演贝托·奥罗克的员工被问及卡斯特罗与拉美裔联系和讲西班牙语的能力时——显然，卡斯特罗的西班牙语没有贝托说得好——假贝托完全入戏地回应。
Look, Lester, I think it's pretty offensive that you and others continue to say that just because someone doesn't speak Spanish means they can't connect with the Latino vote. There's many ways to connect it. For example, Amy and I are still living in El Paso. I've grown up my entire life there. And so I know the unique challenges that our border community faces.
听着，莱斯特，我认为你和其他人继续说仅仅因为某人不讲西班牙语就意味着他们无法与拉美裔选票建立联系，这相当令人反感。有很多联系的方式。例如，艾米和我还住在埃尔帕索。我一生都在那里长大。所以我知道我们的边境社区面临的独特挑战。
In the mock debate, Castro does a relaxed, solid job deploying the answers that he's been working on. But he also gets to practice interrupting other candidates. And this is important because, again, he is worried that other candidates might hog the stage, and he won't get much time or many questions directed at him. And Castro told me that his natural inclination is not to interrupt.
在模拟辩论中，卡斯特罗在部署他一直在研究的答案时表现得轻松、扎实。但他也得到了练习打断其他候选人的机会。这很重要，因为，再说一次，他担心其他候选人可能会垄断舞台，而他得不到太多时间或指向他的问题。卡斯特罗告诉我，他的自然倾向不是打断别人。
I mean, for me, I'm not naturally the guy in a group that has to talk all the time, like they would call gunners in law school. You know gunners? People that would, in law school classes, that basically would be the ones always trying to answer the question that a professor would throw out. That's not me.
我的意思是，对我来说，我自然不是一群人中那种必须一直说话的人，就像他们在法学院被称为“枪手”那样。你知道“枪手”吗？那些在法学院课堂上，基本上总是试图回答教授提出的问题的那些人。那不是我。
I don't know if that's spin or not. But to make sure he does get to talk in the debate, he's keeping in his back pocket two little speeches that he knows are really strong, that if needs be, he's going to bust in and interrupt somebody with. They're actually listed. These two speeches are listed on a flip chart page on the wall that is titled "Interruptions." One of them is listed as "Police Brutality." And in the mock debate, he practices jumping in on another candidate's answer, the guy playing de Blasio, to deliver this.
我不知道那是公关还是什么。但为了确保他确实能在辩论中发言，他在后兜里准备了两段他知道非常强有力的简短演讲，如果有必要，他会闯进去打断某人。它们实际上被列出来了。这两段演讲被列在墙上一个标题为“打断”的翻页挂图页面上。其中一段被列为“警察暴行”。在模拟辩论中，他练习在另一个人——扮演德布拉西奥的家伙——的回答中插话，发表这个。
I've been able to deal with this as an executive of America's biggest city. Small town--
作为美国最大城市的行政长官，我能够处理这个问题。小城镇——
You know, Ken-- Lester, this is important to me. And I've been an executive, too.
你知道，肯——莱斯特，这对我来说很重要。而且我也是一名行政长官。
And then Castro delivers an answer that he knows really works.
然后卡斯特罗发表了一个他知道确实有效的答案。
But it made me think, what about Eric Garner? And what about Tamir Rice? And what about Michael Brown? What about Laquan McDonald?
但这让我想到，埃里克·加纳怎么办？塔米尔·赖斯怎么办？迈克尔·布朗怎么办？拉昆·麦克唐纳怎么办？
At the real debate, Castro delivered a version of that same speech. But that was not the moment that made him the breakout star. There was also not any of the meticulously crafted three-part messages that I watched him labor over.
在真正的辩论中，卡斯特罗发表了那篇演讲的一个版本。但那不是让他成为黑马的时刻。也不是我看到他努力制作的任何精心制作的三部分信息。
And OK, just to step back, if you saw the Democratic debate, you know that the big clip from the second night was Kamala Harris challenging Joe Biden on race. But the big clip from the first night was the other item on Castro's flip chart, list of interruptions. On the chart, it just said "1325 Immigration."
好的，退一步说，如果你看了民主党辩论，你就知道第二晚的大片段是卡玛拉·哈里斯就种族问题挑战乔·拜登。但第一晚的大片段是卡斯特罗翻页挂图上中断列表中的另一个项目。在图表上，它只写着“1325移民”。
Now 1325, if you're not following this, is the part of the immigration law that makes crossing the border a criminal offense. Castro wants to get rid of that. It would still be illegal to cross the border, but you wouldn't face criminal charges. And the day after I watched him prep, Elizabeth Warren came out in the Huffington Post saying, yeah, I'm with Castro on this 1325 stuff.
现在1325，如果你不关注这个，是移民法中将越过边境定为刑事犯罪的那一部分。卡斯特罗想废除它。越过边境仍然是非法的，但你不会面临刑事指控。在我看他准备工作的第二天，伊丽莎白·沃伦在《赫芬顿邮报》上说，是的，在这些1325的事情上，我支持卡斯特罗。
So that was the day before the debate. And seeing that, Castro and his staff to talk about maybe they should do more with 1325 in the debate. And they talked in the past about Castro maybe challenging the other candidates on stage to join his position on 1325, but now they decided, yeah, it's not really a maybe. He really should try to make that happen. And Castro walked on stage looking for an opening, which he got about half an hour in.
那是辩论前一天。看到这一点，卡斯特罗和他的员工谈论也许他们应该在辩论中对1325做更多的事情。他们过去谈论过卡斯特罗也许会挑战台上的其他候选人加入他对1325的立场，但现在他们决定，是的，这不是真正的也许。他真的应该尝试让这种情况发生。卡斯特罗走上舞台寻找机会，他在半小时后得到了。
I will make sure that, number one, we end the ICE policies.
我会确保，第一，我们结束ICE政策。
Cory Booker is answering a question about immigration. As planned, Julián pounces.
科里·布克正在回答一个关于移民的问题。按计划，胡利安猛扑过去。
We actually will lose security and our values. We must fight for both.
我们实际上会失去安全和我们的价值观。我们必须为两者而战。
If I might very briefly-- and this is an important point. My plan-- and I'm glad to see that Senator Booker, Senator Warren, and Governor Inslee agree with me on this-- my plan also includes getting rid of Section 1325 of the Immigration and Nationality Act.
如果我可以非常简短地说——这是一个重要的点。我的计划——我很高兴看到布克参议员、沃伦参议员和英斯利州长在这个问题上同意我的观点——我的计划还包括废除《移民与国籍法》第1325条。
He then explains 1325.
然后他解释了1325。
And so I want to challenge every single candidate on this stage to support the repeal of Section 1325.
所以我想要挑战这个舞台上的每一位候选人支持废除第1325条。
The next question is to Beto O'Rourke, and again, Castro swoops in.
下一个问题是给贝托·奥罗克的，卡斯特罗再次冲了过来。
We would not put kids in cages. In fact, we would spare no expense to reunite the families that have been separated already.
我们不会把孩子关在笼子里。事实上，我们会不惜一切代价让已经分离的家庭团聚。
This is the exchange that ends up the biggest one of the night. And of course, the thing that made it pop is that all the preparation led to this unprepared, unscripted moment. Unlike all those careful one-minute answers that Julián rehearsed, this felt like and real.
这是最终成为当晚最大的交流。当然，让它流行起来的是所有的准备工作导致了这个毫无准备、毫无剧本的时刻。不像胡利安排练过的那些小心翼翼的一分钟回答，这感觉很真实。
Let me respond to this very briefly. Actually, as a member of Congress, I helped to introduce legislation that would ensure that we don't criminalize those who are seeking asylum and refuge in this country.
让我非常简短地回应一下。实际上，作为国会议员，我帮助引入了立法，以确保我们不会将那些在这个国家寻求庇护和避难的人定为罪犯。
I'm not talking about the ones that are seeking asylum.
我不是在说那些寻求庇护的人。
If you're fleeing desperation, then I want to make sure--
如果你在逃离绝望，那么我想要确保——
I'm talking about everybody else.
我在说其他人。
--everybody treated with respect.
——每个人都受到尊重。
I'm still talking about everybody else.
我还在说其他人。
But you're looking at--
但你正在看着——
It all culminates with this.
这一切最终达到了高潮。
I think that you should do your homework on this issue. If you did your homework on this issue, you would know that we should repeal this section.
我认为你应该在这个问题上做你的家庭作业。如果你在这个问题上做了家庭作业，你就会知道我们应该废除这一条。
It was Castro that came out of nowhere. Nobody was talking about Castro. He did the Texas takedown. Turned around, clocked Beto.
是卡斯特罗不知从哪冒出来的。没人谈论卡斯特罗。他进行了得克萨斯式的击倒。转过身，给了贝托一拳。
This is Van Jones on CNN that night.
这是当晚CNN上的范·琼斯。
I mean, you never saw it coming. He bought himself a lifeline tonight. And that's why I love these debates.
我的意思是，你从没预见到它。他今晚为自己赢得了一条生路。这就是为什么我喜欢这些辩论。
A lot of the media agreed, and lots of people on Twitter. Google reported a leap in people searching for Castro's name. And it led the campaign to its biggest fundraising day ever, 32 times more than just before the debate. Castro was suddenly invited to be on Morning Joe and tons of other TV shows. The only thing that had not gone optimally was his exit from the stage at the end of the debate. Derek had advised him.
很多媒体同意，推特上的很多人也同意。谷歌报道称，搜索卡斯特罗名字的人数激增。它带领竞选团队迎来了有史以来最大的筹款日，是辩论前32倍。卡斯特罗突然被邀请参加《早安乔》和许多其他电视节目。唯一没有达到最佳状态的是他在辩论结束时离场。德里克建议过他。
I would suggest go talk to Elizabeth Warren as quickly as possible.
我建议尽快和伊丽莎白·沃伦谈谈。
Yeah.
是的。
Like the dynamic--
比如那种动态——
Oh, you mean because you know that the focus is [INAUDIBLE]
哦，你是说因为你知道重点是[听不清]
The dynamic of you, Booker, and Warren genuinely liking each other will be something that will be good for the [INAUDIBLE].
你、布克和沃伦真正喜欢对方的动态将对[听不清]有好处。
In fact, at the debate's end, Cory Booker is the one who got to Warren first, and they hugged, while Castro was shaking Tim Ryan's hand. And then Warren walked over to Castro, and they embraced. So it worked out in the end even there, just fine. Overall, a win.
事实上，在辩论结束时，科里·布克是第一个到达沃伦那里的人，他们拥抱了，而卡斯特罗正在和蒂姆·瑞安握手。然后沃伦走到卡斯特罗身边，他们拥抱了。所以最终结果很好，甚至在那里也很好。总的来说，是一场胜利。
And a week after his breakaway performance in that first debate, Castro was no longer a 1%-er, at least in one poll. ABC News poll put him at 4%, same as Buttigieg, and just below the four frontrunners, Biden, Sanders, Warren, and Harris.
在那场第一次辩论中取得突破性表现的一周后，卡斯特罗不再是1%的人了，至少在一次民调中。ABC新闻民调让他达到了4%，与布蒂吉格相同，仅次于四位领跑者：拜登、桑德斯、沃伦和哈里斯。
Coming up, we tell you who's going to win the election. Kidding. We did, though, record a candidate who decided to just bribe a voter with $12,000. No joke. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，我们将告诉你谁将赢得选举。开玩笑的。不过，我们确实录下了一位决定只是贿赂选民12,000美元的候选人。没开玩笑。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
Hey.
嘿。
Hey. First time we're in the studio together.
嘿。我们第一次在录音室一起录音。
It is the first time we're in the studio together.
这是我们第一次在录音室一起录音。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. Let's do this.
是的。我们开始吧。
And you had this kind of amazing cinematic recording that you're going to play for the people right now.
你刚才有那种令人惊叹的电影般的录音，你现在要给人们播放。
Yeah. So I was down in South Carolina and Columbia. And I had this opportunity to pin a mic to Cory Booker, one of the people running for president.
是的。我当时在南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚市。我有机会给正在竞选总统的人之一科里·布克别上了麦克风。
Mayor of Newark, New Jersey and now Senator of the United States.
新泽西州纽瓦克市市长，现在是美国参议员。
Yep, both of those things. And so this recording, it starts we're inside of a building. And then it goes outside, and he's sort of walking this distance to go and give a speech. And it's basically just his point of view in this moment, which is what I like about it so much.
是的，两件事都是。所以这段录音，它开始时我们在建筑物里面。然后它走到外面，他正走这一段距离去发表讲话。这基本上只是他那一刻的视角，这就是我非常喜欢它的原因。
You can put it on this side.
你可以把它放在这一边。
OK. I can double mic you on the same side.
好的。我可以把你双重麦克风放在同一边。
Absolutely.
绝对可以。
OK.
好的。
Senator, you ready?
参议员，准备好了吗？
Switch pocket.
换个口袋。
Yes.
是的。
I'm going to hand you this. You have about 50 people outside, cheering your name. Cheer them on, and then we're going to march. Just follow me the whole way.
我要把这个递给你。你在外面有大约50个人，在欢呼你的名字。为他们加油，然后我们去行进。就跟着我全程走。
OK.
好的。
Everyone's going to be behind you, and press is in front of me.
每个人都会在你后面，媒体在我前面。
OK.
好的。
All right, ready?
好了，准备好了吗？
All right.
好了。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼声]
All right! All right! This is amazing!
好了！好了！这太神奇了！
Cory! Cory! Cory! Cory! Cory! Cory!
科里！科里！科里！科里！科里！科里！
I love you guys!
我爱你们！
So in that moment, he just sort of flips from a normal person having a conversation to this super-sized human with a megaphone.
所以在那一刻，他从一个正在交谈的普通人变成了一个拿着扩音器的超级人类。
This is what democracy looks like!
这就是民主的样子！
We will rise! We will rise! Everybody, follow me!
我们将崛起！我们将崛起！大家，跟着我！
What a weird job these guys have. You walk out into a crowd, and then suddenly, you're supposed to lead the crowd.
这些家伙的工作真奇怪。你走进人群，然后突然之间，你应该领导人群。
Yeah. And there's all these people surrounding him. They've got giant posters of his head, like these Cory Booker head posters.
是的。而且周围都是这些人。他们拿着巨大的海报，写着他的头，就像这些科里·布克头的海报。
Wait, wait. So you're there in a crowd, and there's Cory Booker's real bald head. And then in addition, there's giant bald Cory Booker heads?
等等，等等。所以你在人群中，那是科里·布克真实的秃头。此外，还有巨大的秃头科里·布克头？
Yeah, floating around behind him.
是的，在他身后漂浮着。
Cory Booker is the best!
科里·布克最棒了！
Can't you say that's like a weird nightmare image, in a way?
难道你不能说那是一种奇怪的噩梦形象吗，从某种意义上说？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's very friendly faces, smiling.
那是非常友好的面孔，微笑着。
That is true. That's true, yes.
那是真的。那是真的，是的。
And so they're walking in this giant crowd. And as they're crossing the street, someone comes up to him. And I can't make out exactly what she's saying. I think she's a journalist. And it seems like she's asking a question about the latest sexual assault allegations against President Trump.
所以他们正走在这一大群人中。当他们穿过街道时，有人走近他。我无法完全听清她在说什么。我觉得她是名记者。看起来她正在问一个关于对特朗普总统最新的性侵犯指控的问题。
No, this is not the ideal time to talk about this. And why don't you reach out to my team? But it's very disturbing.
不，这不是谈论这个的理想时间。为什么你不联系我的团队？但这是非常令人不安的。
What hit me is just everybody wants his attention and his time. The press is in front of him. They've got cameras pointed at him. He's got an aide who's telling him where to go. And then he's leading this group of people, clapping and cheering while walking. It's just so much at once.
打击我的是每个人都想要他的注意力和时间。媒体在他前面。他们的摄像机对准了他。他有一个告诉他去哪里的助手。然后他领导着这群人，在走路时鼓掌欢呼。这真的太多了，一次性。
Give me a Y! Y! [INAUDIBLE] Give me a C! C!
给我一个Y！Y！[听不清] 给我一个C！C！
So he's clapping. And then in the middle of all this, someone else walks up to him.
所以他在鼓掌。然后在这一切之中，另一个人走近他。
God bless you, brother. God bless you, brother. [LAUGHS]
上帝保佑你，兄弟。上帝保佑你，兄弟。[笑声]
It's Jesse Jackson, the civil rights icon, former presidential candidate.
那是杰西·杰克逊，民权偶像，前总统候选人。
Wow.
哇。
Jesse Jackson is someone who Booker actually talks about sometimes as the first presidential candidate that he ever voted for. And he's just standing next to him. He just pops out of nowhere, and then he's at Booker's side. We're in South Carolina, remember? Jesse Jackson--
杰西·杰克逊有时是布克提到的是他投过票的第一位总统候选人。他就站在他旁边。他不知从哪冒出来，然后他就在布克身边了。我们是在南卡罗来纳州，记住？杰西·杰克逊——
Huge black vote-- every candidate's got to try to get it.
巨大的黑人选票——每一位候选人都必须努力去争取。
Yeah. And I mean, Jesse Jackson's not the worst person to stand next to. He's from South Carolina. People, they remember when he ran for president. So you sort of have these two black men in dark suits, one of them who tried to be president and the other one who's trying to do so now, parading down the street together.
是的。我的意思是，杰西·杰克逊站在旁边不是最糟糕的人。他来自南卡罗来纳州。人们，他们记得他竞选总统的时候。所以你有一种这两个穿深色西装的黑人男人的感觉，其中一个人试图成为总统，另一个人现在正在努力这样做，一起走在街上。
Yeah, I'm getting ready to go and speak now.
是的，我现在正准备去演讲。
Jackson is hard to hear. He has Parkinson's. He speaks slow and stumbly, and I don't have a mic on him. Booker seems pretty chummy. He basically says, yes, we need to talk. We need to have a conversation, but not now.
杰克逊很难听清楚。他患有帕金森症。他说话慢且迟钝，我没有麦克风对他。布克看起来很亲热。他基本上说，是的，我们需要谈谈。我们需要交谈，但现在不行。
I'll try to reach out on the number I have for you, but I want to talk to you when we're not-- all this craziness going around. So maybe tomorrow after church? Are you still going to be down here?
我会尝试用我有的号码联系你，但我想在我们不是——所有这些疯狂发生时和你谈话。所以也许明天教堂之后？你还会在这里吗？
In Chicago.
在芝加哥。
Oh.
哦。
We often see pictures like this, right? Like leaders in suits and conversation in this public space. And I don't know. I like to think of the conversations they're having are about these great and epic things. But maybe they're actually just scheduling phone calls. [LAUGHS]
我们经常看到这样的照片，对吧？就像西装革履的领导人在公共空间交谈。我不知道。我喜欢认为他们进行的对话是关于这些伟大和史诗般的事情。但也许他们实际上只是在安排电话。[笑声]
So let's just talk on the phone, OK? We need to have a heart-to-heart sooner or later. But look, you are doing it right now. You're continuing to keep people's eyes on justice. Thank you. Love you.
所以让我们在电话里谈吧，好吗？我们需要迟早有一次掏心窝子的谈话。但听着，你现在正在做这件事。你继续让人们的眼睛盯着正义。谢谢。爱你。
You can hear that Corey says love you to Jackson. I'm not sure if he says it back. I just can't hear it.
你可以听到科里对杰克逊说爱你。我不确定他是否回应了。我只是听不到。
Or Jackson might just be like in Star Wars. I love you. I know.
或者杰克逊可能就像在星球大战里一样。我爱你。我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
Jackson leaves him hanging.
杰克逊让他悬着。
I don't think so. I imagine that he returned the expression.
我不这么认为。我想象他回应了这个表达。
We don't know for sure, though.
不过我们不确定。
And that was only five minutes and 47 seconds of his day. And it was so intense.
那只是他一天中5分47秒的内容。而且太激烈了。
Yeah.
是的。
And here's what else he did that day. He had a faith breakfast, barbershop meet-and-greet, Planned Parenthood forum, convention center speech, and then another meet-and-greet. Also, he's a senator. That was just a moment of his day. And I can't imagine having an entire day like that.
这就是他那天做的其他事情。他有一个信仰早餐、理发店见面会、计划生育论坛、会议中心演讲，然后是另一个见面会。此外，他还是位参议员。那只是他一天的瞬间。我无法想象过那样的一整天。
Ugh, it's so much work, and he's not even a frontrunner.
呃，这工作量太大了，而且他甚至不是领跑者。
It's so much work just to be there.
光是站在那里就需要做这么多工作。
So now I'm joined in the studio by Ben Calhoun. Hey there.
所以现在本·卡尔霍恩加入我的录音室了。嘿。
Hey.
嘿。
So you went out with one of the 20 or so underdogs in the race, Andrew Yang. And Yang, I think, is interesting because he's actually managed to get a lot more attention than most of the underdogs.
所以你和这场竞选中的20个左右弱势群体候选人之一，杨安泽一起出去了。杨，我觉得很有趣，因为他实际上比大多数弱势候选人设法获得了更多的关注。
Yeah. He's been doing things like getting on cable shows, profiles in Vanity Fair, Washington Post. And so now he's in this position where he's just trying to fan like whatever little flames he's kindled up until this point.
是的。他一直在做一些事情，比如上电视节目，在《名利场》、《华盛顿邮报》上亮相。所以现在他处于这种位置，他只是试图煽动他到目前为止点燃的任何小火苗。
And he's gotten that attention because, well, if you know who this guy is, he's this tech guy, former businessman, who organized his whole campaign around this one idea.
他得到这种关注是因为，嗯，如果你知道这家伙是谁，他是个科技大亨，前商人，他围绕这个想法组织了他的整个竞选。
Yeah, and the idea is that we should give every working age American $1,000 a month. Because what Yang says is he says this whole country is in this big crisis where workers are being replaced by automation and technology. And he thinks that when Democrats usually talk about this, their solutions are weak sauce. He says job retraining programs--
是的，这个想法是我们应该给每个工作年龄的美国人每月1,000美元。因为杨所说的是，他说整个国家正处于一场巨大的危机中，工人正在被自动化和技术所取代。他认为当民主党人通常谈论这个时，他们的解决方案很软弱。他说工作再培训计划——
The Democrats talk about that a lot.
民主党人经常谈论那个。
Yeah, job retraining. And he says the studies show that they don't work for most people. And most people kind of feel that in their gut.
是的，工作再培训。他说研究表明它们对大多数人不起作用。大多数人从直觉上感觉得到。
Because it is bull [BLEEP]. And national politicians will talk about retraining until they're blue in the face. They love it, [LAUGHS] because they're far from the group of people that are getting displaced. But if you get close-- I was at a truck stop here in Iowa, Iowa 80. And you walk around there, talking about retraining to those guys, you'll probably get a fist to the face. [LAUGHS] It's irresponsible to talk about that as a mass solution.
因为这是废话。全国政客们会谈论再培训直到他们面红耳赤。他们喜欢它，[笑声]因为他们离被取代的那群人很远。但如果你接近——我在爱荷华州的一个卡车停靠站，爱荷华80。你在那里走动，和那些家伙谈论再培训，你可能会脸部挨上一拳。[笑声] 把这作为一种群众性解决方案来谈论是不负责任的。
So $1,000 a month, which Yang admits, it's not enough for somebody to live on, but he says it's enough to keep somebody afloat. The name for that is Universal Basic Income, UBI. Yang's calling his version of this the Freedom Dividend. But so I went to go see him. He's going to demonstrate how this would work by actually giving somebody $1,000 a month, no strings attached.
所以每月1,000美元，杨承认，这不足以让某人生活，但他说这足以让某人维持生存。这叫做全民基本收入，UBI。杨称他的这个版本为“自由红利”。但所以我去看了他。他要演示这是如何工作的，通过实际给某人每月1,000美元，没有附加条件。
For a year?
一年？
A whole year out of his pocket.
自掏腰包整整一年。
OK. So tell what happened.
好的。所以告诉我发生了什么。
So the night before this thing, I'm in the car with Yang and his campaign. And I've been recording them all day. Now it's like 9:30 PM. Everybody's pretty tired.
所以这件事的前一天晚上，我和杨以及他的竞选团队在车里。我已经录了他们一整天。现在是晚上9:30。每个人都相当累。
So it's an hour and a half from here. We need to be somewhere at 10:45, so we need to leave--
所以离这里有一个半小时。我们需要在10:45出现在某个地方，所以我们需要离开——
And they're talking about this UBI event. Yang's like, I'm so psyched. But then right away, there's this logistical problem. To give away $1,000, you need to hand people something. And he doesn't have $1,000 on him.
他们在谈论这个UBI活动。杨说，我太兴奋了。但随即，出现了一个物流问题。为了送出1,000美元，你需要交给人们什么东西。而且他身上没有1,000美元。
What they want to do is like-- I've gotta stop by an ATM and--
他们想要做的是像——我得顺便去个ATM和——
OK, it's pretty much impossible to hear. I'm way in the back. I'm behind Yang's campaign manager, Zach Graumann, and Yang. They're up in front. So I'm just going to tell you how a lot of this dialogue goes.
好的，几乎不可能听清。我在后面。我在杨的竞选经理扎克·格劳曼和杨后面。他们在前面。所以我只是要告诉你很多对话是怎么进行的。
In that tape there, Yang says, I need to stop by an ATM and get a lot of cash, right? Because Ed McMahon doesn't show up at your house and just tell you you've won publisher's clearing house. That would be lame. You take a photo with the big check. So Yang's like, I got to get out a bunch of cash, to which his campaign manager says, well--
在那盘带子里，杨说，我需要顺便去个ATM取很多现金，对吧？因为埃德·麦克马洪不会出现在你家门口就告诉你你赢了出版商清算所。那太蹩脚了。你拿着大支票拍照。所以杨说，我得取出一大堆现金，他的竞选经理说，嗯——
So you cannot give cash. We need to think about this.
所以你不能给现金。我们需要考虑一下。
"So you cannot give cash. We need to think about this," he says. And he gives this big sigh. Because shockingly, the Federal Elections Commission has a problem with a candidate for president giving a voter $12,000 in cash. Go figure. But also apparently, it's fine if that money comes in the form of a check. Again, go figure. Questions start flying. Does anybody have a check? Hey, what about Don?
“所以你不能给现金。我们需要考虑一下，”他说。他发出了这声沉重的叹息。因为令人震惊的是，联邦选举委员会对于总统候选人给选民12,000美元现金有问题。去想吧。但同样显然，如果那笔钱以支票形式出现，那是可以的。再说一次，去想吧。问题开始飞来了。谁有支票？嘿，唐怎么样？
Don's son would probably have a check, right? Don's son [INAUDIBLE].
唐的儿子应该有支票，对吧？唐的儿子[听不清]。
I can go to a bank and get a check, right?
我可以去银行拿张支票，对吧？
Yang, meantime, gets out his wallet and starts counting how much cash he has on him. $270, it turns out. And then he starts asking how much ATM limits are. How about a cashier's check, someone says, at a Walgreens on Sunday morning?
杨，同时，拿出他的钱包开始数他身上有多少现金。结果是270美元。然后他开始问ATM限额是多少。有人说，周日早上在沃尔格林拿张现金支票怎么样？
Getting to a Walgreens before 9:00 AM tomorrow.
明天早上9点前去沃尔格林。
That's not impossible.
那不是不可能。
I'm in a car with a candidate for the presidency of the United States of America who's trying to sell the marquee idea of his campaign, the concept he thinks will save America. And the question of the moment is, can you get a cashier's check at a Walgreens in Des Moines on Sunday morning before 9:00 AM?
我正坐在美国总统候选人的车里，他正试图推销他竞选的核心想法，那个他认为能拯救美国的概念。而当下的问题是，你能在周日早上9点前在得梅因的沃尔格林拿到现金支票吗？
The next day, we go to the house of the Freedom Dividend recipients, Kyle and Pam Christiansen. At this point, the campaign hasn't told them they're getting the money, just that they're being considered as finalists. Yang isn't with us. He's waiting to make a surprise entrance.
第二天，我们去了自由红利接受者凯尔和帕姆·克里斯蒂安森的家。此时，竞选团队还没告诉他们他们要拿钱，只是说他们正在被考虑作为决赛选手。杨没和我们在一起。他正在等待做一个惊喜的进入。
His staff was not able to get a cashier's check. So instead, Yang has a grand in $20 bills. That means that, legally, the campaign is going to have to hand the Christiansens the money for this photo op, but then take it back afterwards and promise to mail them a check, which seems really pretty tacky to me. But everyone with the Yang campaign is like, we'll figure it out.
他的员工没能拿到现金支票。所以相反，杨有1,000美元的20美元钞票。这意味着，在法律上，竞选团队将不得不为这次拍照把钱交给克里斯蒂安森一家，但之后得把钱收回去，并承诺给他们寄一张支票，这对我来说看起来真的很俗气。但杨竞选团队的每个人都说，我们会搞定的。
Hi. I'm Zach.
嗨。我是扎克。
I'm Pam.
我是帕姆。
Nice to meet you in person, Pam. How are you?
很高兴见到你，帕姆。你好吗？
The campaign, I've got to say, picked a really lovely family to get this. Kyle, the son, is 41. He'd applied for this Freedom Dividend on behalf of his mom. About four years ago, the family lost Kyle's dad, Merle, to brain cancer. They seemed like such a tight, loving family.
我必须说，竞选团队挑选了一个非常可爱的家庭来获得这个。凯尔，儿子，41岁。他代他母亲申请了这个自由红利。大约四年前，这个家庭失去了凯尔的爸爸，默尔，死于脑癌。他们看起来是一个如此紧密、有爱的家庭。
Merle was a musician. And in their house, every Wednesday, it was music night. They'd play records-- Kiss, Black Sabbath. Merle would play drums, and the kids would dance around, which is how, I suppose, Kyle ended up being a musician, too.
默尔是一名音乐家。在他们家里，每周三是音乐之夜。他们会放唱片——KISS，黑色安息日。默尔会打鼓，孩子们会跳舞，我想，这就是凯尔最终也成为音乐家的原因。
Anyway, about a year after Merle died, Pam was also diagnosed with cancer. The day she was diagnosed-- her birthday-- her boss called her to tell her he was firing her because she'd had to miss too much work. Pam worked as an aide for disabled adults, which she said was hard, but she loved it.
总之，默尔去世大约一年后，帕姆也被诊断出癌症。她被诊断出的那天——她的生日——她的老板打电话告诉她他要解雇她，因为她不得不缺席太多工作。帕姆曾是一名残疾成年人的助手，她说这很难，但她喜欢它。
After that, Kyle dedicated himself to taking care of Pam. And Pam, now in remission, still has a hard time getting around. Kyle's been piecing together work-- auto repair, computer repair, music work when he can get it. But it's hard making sure he's there for his mom.
那之后，凯尔致力于照顾帕姆。帕姆现在处于缓解期，仍然很难四处走动。凯尔一直在拼凑工作——汽车维修、电脑维修、音乐工作。但确保他在他妈妈身边很难。
The monthly bills are about $1,300, and they barely get covered. So $1,000 would mean a lot. Kyle, though, he says he'd like to see his mom spend at least some of this imaginary money, even just a little, on something genuinely frivolous.
每月的账单大约是1,300美元，几乎无法支付。所以1,000美元意义重大。凯尔，不过，他说他想看到他妈妈在这笔想象中的钱里至少花一些，即使是一点点，在真正轻浮的事情上。
Yeah, I'd just like to see her just go buy something because she wants to and not out of necessity.
是的，我只是想看到她因为想要而买点什么，而不是因为必要。
But there's priorities, too, so.
但也有优先事项，所以。
Well, what are some of the things that-- I feel like you get sick, those bills pile up, you start to give things up. I mean, what are some of the things that you've given up in the last few years?
嗯，有些什么事情——我觉得你生病了，那些账单堆积起来，你开始放弃东西。我的意思是，过去几年你放弃了什么？
Are you talking about like what we have given up, or sold, or that kind of stuff?
你在谈论我们放弃了什么，或者卖掉了什么，或者那种事情吗？
Yeah. Just like-- yeah, just since the money's been tighter.
是的。只是——是的，自从钱变得更紧之后。
Yeah, I know for me, I used to have a full-blown recording studio here in town. And I've always kind of held on to all that equipment hoping to set one up somewhere. I've sold darn near all that equipment, and just kind of have bare bones, bare minimum. I sold my last two guitars that I could possibly part with last week. So-- oh my gosh, there's Andrew Yang himself.
是的，我知道对我来说，我曾经在城里有一个完整的录音室。我一直希望在这里设置一个。我把所有那些设备都卖掉了，只剩下光秃秃的，最低限度的。我上周卖掉了我最后两把还能卖的吉他。所以——噢，天哪，那是安德鲁·杨本人。
[DOOR BELL RINGS]
[门铃响]
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Kyle later told me, when he'd asked the campaign if Yang was coming, the staffer he was talking to on the phone hesitated and then said, no, in this way that Kyle figured Yang probably was coming. But he and Pam both act surprised. Andrew Yang offers to take off his shoes in the house.
凯尔后来告诉我，当他问竞选团队杨是否要来时，他电话里交谈的那个员工犹豫了一下，然后说了不，以一种凯尔推测杨可能要来的方式。但他和帕姆都表现得大吃一惊。安德鲁·杨主动提出在屋里脱掉鞋子。
Nope, nope, you're fine.
不，不，你没问题。
I am Asian, so.
我是亚裔，所以。
No, come on.
不，别。
I'll take them off.
我会脱掉它们的。
Hey, Mr. Yang. How are you?
嘿，杨先生。你好吗？
I'm doing great. You must be Pam.
我很好。你一定是帕姆。
Yes, I'm Pam.
是的，我是帕姆。
Thank you for having me here.
谢谢你邀请我。
Yes.
是的。
So I'm here to let you know that you will be receiving the Iowa Freedom Dividend starting July 1.
所以我在这里让你知道，你将从7月1日开始收到爱荷华州自由红利。
Oh!
噢！
So congratulations.
所以恭喜。
Thank you.
谢谢。
If Yang did this for everyone, if he gave every adult $12,000 a year, it would cost the government $2 trillion, give or take. The current federal budget is $4 trillion. So we're talking about a massive realignment of the economy and redistribution of wealth. Yang has projections on how all this could be paid for, and they include some very optimistic assumptions, all for a theory that's never been tested on anywhere near the scale.
如果杨对每个人都这样做，如果他给每个成年人每年12,000美元，那将花费政府2万亿美元左右。目前的联邦预算是4万亿美元。所以我们在谈论经济的重大重组和财富的重新分配。杨对于这一切如何支付有预测，它们包括一些非常乐观的假设，全部基于一个从未在任何接近那个规模的地方进行过测试的理论。
Yang starts to explain to the Christiansens how this is going to work for them. But mostly, he tells them how grateful he is to help them out, in a way that feels pretty nice, actually. And it kind of drains a little awkwardness out of a very manufactured situation.
杨开始向克里斯蒂安森一家解释这将如何为他们工作。但大多时候，他告诉他们他有多感激能帮助他们，以一种感觉相当不错的方式。它从一个非常制造出来的情况下抽走了一点尴尬。
So we need to do this for people all over the country, but starting here with you all to illustrate the fact that if people get some extra money in their hands, it's going to go to the things that we care about and value. I mean, it's an awesome opportunity for us. So thank you for making it possible. Give me a hug. No problem.
所以我们需要为全国各地的人们做这件事，但从你们所有人开始，以说明如果人们手里有一些额外的钱，它会流向我们关心和重视的事情。我的意思是，这对我们来说是一个很棒的机会。所以谢谢你让这成为可能。给我个拥抱。没问题。
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。
You guys are very, very welcome.
你们非常非常受欢迎。
The next 45 minutes are completely usual and unusual. Yang genuinely asks Pam and Kyle about their situation-- Pam's neuropathy, her treatment. He talks again and again about how much he admires Kyle for taking care of his mom. Kyle talks about the one doctor's appointment he's missed in the last three years. They talk about music, how Kyle quit the metal band he was touring with because he loved performing, but he never had an interest in the drinking and drugs that went with it. They laugh about Yang's flag socks. He talks about picking them out.
接下来的45分钟是完全平常和不平常的。杨真诚地问帕姆和凯尔关于他们的情况——帕姆的神经病变，她的治疗。他一再谈论他有多么钦佩凯尔照顾他妈妈。凯尔谈论他过去三年错过的一次医生的预约。他们谈论音乐，凯尔如何退出了他巡演的金属乐队，因为他喜欢表演，但他对伴随表演的饮酒和药物从不感兴趣。他们笑着杨的旗帜袜子。他谈论挑选它们。
Like so little of political campaigning, it's unrushed enough to feel regular. Until it's time to go and the surreal logistics of a political campaign break through this small bubble of normality. Yang has to hit the road.
政治竞选活动中很少有这种情况，它足够从容，感觉很平常。直到该离开的时候，政治竞选的超现实物流打破了这个小的常态泡沫。杨必须上路了。
I feel like this is a weird and particular thing you see when politicians campaign. So many of their interactions are superficial and crassly abbreviated. And then sometimes, like in this room, they'll just drift into a space with some voters that feels intense, and authentic, and personal. And then poof, time to go.
我觉得这是你看到政治家竞选时一种奇怪而特殊的事情。他们的许多互动是肤浅和粗俗简略的。然后有时，就像在这个房间里，他们会漂移到一些选民的空间里，感觉很激烈、真实和个人。然后砰，该走了。
Before Yang's got to leave, though, they have to pose for pictures. They have to pose with the cash, the cash they need, but won't be allowed to keep. After the pictures, they'll hand it back. For now, Yang pulls out this huge wad of twenties. Pam, with some struggle, stands up. And Yang hands each of them a stack.
不过，在杨不得不离开之前，他们必须摆姿势拍照。他们必须和现金摆姿势，他们需要的现金，但不被允许保留。照片拍完后，他们会把它还回去。现在，杨拿出一大卷二十美元钞票。帕姆，带着一些挣扎，站了起来。杨把一叠交给他们每个人。
Yeah, can you fan it?
是的，你能扇形展开它吗？
Can you guys fan it?
你们能扇形展开它吗？
They fan out the money. And then they look for which lens to smile into.
他们把钱扇形展开。然后他们寻找该对着哪个镜头微笑。
There you go.
好了。
Split it in half. His pile's bigger than mine.
对半分。他的那叠比我的大。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Not that I'm counting, but--
不是我在数，但是——
[CAMERA CLICKING]
[相机咔哒声]
And one, this is for Instagram.
还有一个，这是给Instagram的。
Ben Calhoun. Hey, Ben?
本·卡尔霍恩。嘿，本？
Yeah.
是的。
I see in the poll numbers that he's still stuck at the bottom.
我在民调数字中看到他还卡在底部。
Yeah, and I mean, not the bottom, bottom.
是的，我的意思是，不是底部中的底部。
It's so crazy that people aren't voting for this. It reminds me of-- I knew somebody who was an editor at Playboy magazine. Like once the internet hit and Maxim and all those magazines hit, and it was like Playboy was printing pornography, and people wouldn't buy the magazine. And that's what I feel like this is. It's like he's giving away $12,000 to everybody who will vote for him, and people still don't want it.
人们不投这个票真是太疯狂了。这让我想起——我认识一个人，他是《花花公子》杂志的编辑。就像一旦互联网出现，马克西姆和所有那些杂志出现，就像《花花公子》在印刷色情作品，人们不会买那本杂志。我觉得这就是这种情况。就像他给所有投他票的人送去12,000美元，人们仍然不想要它。
Uh-huh. The family did say that they are going to caucus for him, if he's still around in January when the caucuses happen.
嗯哼。那个家庭确实说，如果他在一月份党团会议时还在，他们会在党团会议上投他票。
You have a town hall with the moderate guy who wants to beat up Medicare for All, or you have Gillibrand also at 1% with drag queens. So which of those is more interesting?
你有一个和想要打败全民医保的温和派家伙的市政厅会议，或者你还有支持1%的吉利布兰德和变装皇后。那么哪一个更有趣？
Hi Ira, I'm back.
嘿艾拉，我回来了。
Hey there, Zoe Chace.
嘿，佐伊·蔡斯。
I'm taking you through Iowa with Dave Weigel, the Washington Post reporter.
我正带着你和《华盛顿邮报》记者戴夫·维格尔一起走访爱荷华州。
I know. I feel like you saw so much more than we heard at the top of the show.
我知道。我觉得你看到的比我们在节目开头听到的多得多。
It's kind of crazy the way Weigel wants to go to every single candidate event. That's impossible, because there are too many happening at the same time.
维格尔想要参加每一场候选人活动，这太疯狂了。那是不可能的，因为同时发生的事情太多了。
It's not the hardest decision anyone's ever made. It's like--
这不是任何人做过的最艰难的决定。它就像——
But there's this intense lesson that I think a lot of the reporters learned from 2016, which is that any candidate can surge.
但我觉得很多记者从2016年学到了一个强烈的教训，那就是任何候选人都可能激增。
Oh, you mean because Trump. Like, they didn't foresee that Trump could be the winner.
哦，你是说因为特朗普。比如，他们没预见到特朗普会成为赢家。
Yeah, all the things that indicated who'd come out on top-- like think Jeb Bush, right? He was the front runner. He had all the money. None of those things turned out to matter. So this time around, it's like any event can be the beginning of someone's big run. We went to so many events in just two days.
是的，所有表明谁会脱颖而出的事情——想想杰布·布什，对吧？他是领跑者。他有所有的钱。结果这些事情都没关系。所以这一次，感觉任何活动都可能是某人伟大竞选的开始。我们在短短两天内参加了太多活动。
She saved the mommy. She saved the daddy. She saved--
她拯救了妈妈。她拯救了爸爸。她拯救了——
Kirsten Gillibrand, she wrote a kid's book. And she's reading it at the Y to just two small children, while a handful of people watch them.
克尔斯滕·吉利布兰德，她写了一本儿童书。她在基督教青年会给两个小孩读它，而只有少数几个人看着他们。
Wait, the senator wrote a kid's book?
等等，参议员写了一本儿童书？
Yeah, she wrote a book for kids, but not that many kids showed up to hear it.
是的，她给孩子们写了一本书，但没多少孩子来看。
Be strong and courageous. Do you know what the word courageous means? Do you know what it means? Courageous means brave. Do you know what the word--
要坚强和勇敢。你知道勇敢这个词是什么意思吗？你知道它是什么意思吗？勇敢意味着勇敢。你知道——这个词——
Oh, wow. What a coincidence. Brave just happens to be the theme of her entire campaign.
哦，哇。多巧啊。勇敢恰好是她整个竞选的主题。
That's exactly right. We went to an Iowa Democratic Veterans event where Eric Swalwell, a candidate for president, was supposed to be.
完全正确。我们去了爱荷华州民主党退伍军人活动，总统候选人埃里克·斯沃韦尔本该在那里。
But can you just tell me what's going on? Is he coming? Where is he?
但你能告诉我发生了什么吗？他要来吗？他在哪？
Eric Swalwell? Yeah, his flight was delayed. So staffer made it. He wanted to be here, but delayed flight.
埃里克·斯沃韦尔？是的，他的航班延误了。所以员工到了。他想在这里，但航班延误了。
Got it.
明白了。
We had that from several of them that had scheduling issues. Like, oh, crap, our flight's been bumped.
我们有几个有安排问题的人。比如，噢，糟了，我们的航班被挤掉了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
That's the silliness of waiting until the day of to get into a major event, as opposed to flying in a day early and being prepared.
这就是等到当天进入重大活动，而不是提前一天飞来做好准备的愚蠢之处。
Oh, he's mad.
哦，他生气了。
Yeah, Joe Stutler, secretary of the Iowa Democratic Veterans Caucus. That's a guy you want on your side early on.
是的，乔·斯塔特勒，爱荷华州民主党退伍军人党团秘书。那是个你想要早点拉拢的人。
I used to live on the road. It's like, you get there the day before, if it's important.
我过去经常在路上。它就像，如果你提前一天到达，如果它很重要。
So you're kind of feeling like maybe this wasn't that important to him?
所以你觉得也许这对他来说没那么重要？
No, no. I just think that they're all trying to do way too much. These are the lessons that we learn, sometimes the hard way.
不，不。我只是觉得他们都在试图做太多事情。这些是我们学到的教训，有时是痛苦的。
Of course, there are lots of reporters who have covered these kinds of events a million times, who stand around afterwards nerding out about campaign history, which is kind of awesome.
当然，有很多报道过这类活动一百万次的记者，他们在事后聚在一起，像书呆子一样讨论竞选历史，这简直太棒了。
After Gene McCarthy finished a decent second event in New Hampshire--
在尤金·麦卡锡在新罕布什尔州完成了一场体面的第二场活动后——
Close second to him in New Hampshire, and about to win--
在新罕布什尔州紧随其后，而且即将获胜——
And then Bobby got it.
然后鲍比得到了它。
And Bobby got it in, and then McCarthy was about to win Wisconsin, because Bobby had not gotten on the ballot, if I remember.
然后鲍比得到了它，然后麦卡锡即将赢得威斯康星州，因为鲍比没能进入选票，如果我记得的话。
Right. Yeah.
对。是的。
And also, it's cool to see these guys talking about this moment-- this early moment in the campaign-- in this way, like it might be history later. It might not be, but they're talking about it like it is, like when Weigel and this other reporter were in the back of the room talking about Elizabeth Warren.
而且，看到这些家伙谈论这一刻——竞选的早期时刻——以这种方式，就像它以后可能是历史一样，也很酷。它可能不是，但他们谈论它就像它是，就像维格尔和另一位记者在房间后面谈论伊丽莎白·沃伦时一样。
I remember seeing her at the Sharpton thing.
我记得在沙普顿的事情上见到她。
Yeah.
是的。
The year before.
前一年。
Oh, I was there.
哦，我在那儿。
Yeah. And remember she had a really [INAUDIBLE] speaking time.
是的。记得她有一次真正[听不清]的发言时间。
I took out the dress. You all know the dress.
我拿出了那件衣服。你们都知道那件衣服。
And everybody went [BLEEP] nuts.
然后每个人都[哔]疯了。
Yeah.
是的。
What was her dress line?
她的衣服台词是什么？
So the dress line-- she tells it all the time-- is, when she was a kid-- and she always says, my mama and my daddy, because she's from Oklahoma. But she talks about, I heard my parents in that argument, talking at night after they thought I was asleep. And that's where I learned words like foreclosure and mortgage.
所以衣服台词——她总是讲这个——是，当她还是个孩子时——她总是说，我的妈妈和爸爸，因为她来自俄克拉荷马州。但她谈论，我听到我的父母在争论，在他们以为我睡着后的晚上谈话。那就是我学会“止赎”和“抵押”这些词的地方。
Right.
对。
And I walked past my mother's room, and I saw her puttering-- going back and forth with a dress laid out. And she goes, y'all know the dress. It's the one you only use for graduations and funerals-- weddings, graduations, and funerals. And she looks at the dress and says, we're not going to lose this house. We're not going to lose this house.
我走过我母亲的房间，我看到她来回踱步，摆着一件裙子。她说，你们都知道那件裙子。它是你只用于毕业典礼和葬礼——婚礼、毕业典礼和葬礼。她看着裙子说，我们不会失去这所房子。我们不会失去这所房子。
She does it like in this-- like she's doing it kind of like--
她这样做就像在——她这样做就像——
Like a Tennessee Williams character.
像田纳西·威廉姆斯笔下的角色。
She's, like--
她——
Yeah.
是的。
And the very next day, I saw her give this speech to a pretty big crowd in a backyard in Waterloo, Iowa. Everybody was just kind of rapt.
第二天，我看到她在爱荷华州滑铁卢的一个后院给一大群人演讲。每个人都相当入迷。
And there was the dress, and there was my mother. She was in her slip and her stocking feet. And she was pacing and crying, just talking to herself and saying, we will not lose this house. We will not lose this house. We will not lose this house.
那件裙子在那里，我的母亲也在那里。她穿着内衣，袜子脚。她在踱步和哭泣，只是自言自语说，我们不会失去这所房子。我们不会失去这所房子。我们不会失去这所房子。
And this one guy was wiping tears away. At this point, Weigel can sort of divide the candidates into two groups. And it's not the moderates and the far left. He says, actually, the voters he talks to are less hung up on the policy questions. What they mainly want is to be able to close their eyes and see this person beating Donald Trump.
那个家伙在擦眼泪。在这一点上，维格尔可以将候选人分成两组。这不是温和派和极左派。他说，事实上，他谈话的选民对政策问题不那么纠结。他们主要想要的是能够闭上眼睛，看到这个人击败唐纳德·特朗普。
Hm.
嗯。
The two groups he notices are, one, the candidates where people show up at one of their events, and a transformation happens. The voter leaves the event excited, inspired. The other group are the ones where that transformation doesn't happen.
他注意到的两组是，一，选民出现在他们的活动上，发生转变的候选人。选民离开活动时感到兴奋、受到启发。另一组是没发生那种转变的人。
So who's in the excited group?
所以谁在兴奋组里？
Cory Booker, Pete Buttigieg, and most of all, Elizabeth Warren.
科里·布克、皮特·布蒂吉格，最重要的是，伊丽莎白·沃伦。
Huh.
嗯。
People see her, and they're surprised at how much they like her.
人们看到她，对他们竟然如此喜欢她感到惊讶。
Huh. And the unexcited group?
嗯。那么不兴奋的组呢？
Basically everyone else, including the front runner, Joe Biden. People would come to see him because they already loved him, and then they would leave feeling no different, or worse.
基本上其他人，包括领跑者乔·拜登。人们去看他，因为他们已经爱他了，然后他们离开时感觉没什么不同，或者更糟。
Like they want to be inspired, but they weren't inspired.
就像他们想受到启发，但他们没受到启发。
Yeah. Beto-- people went backwards.
是的。贝托——人们倒退了。
I have all these memories, which already seem surreal, of Beto O'Rourke coming to somewhere and there being an enormous crowd to see him.
我所有这些记忆，看起来已经很超现实，关于贝托·奥罗克来到某处，那里有巨大的人群看着他。
Now it's like the crowd is smaller, and people leave underwhelmed.
现在人群变小了，人们离开时感到失望。
And what does he see changing?
他看到什么在改变？
Since the first debate, at this point, the field is basically sorting itself out.
自第一次辩论以来，在这一点上，战场基本上正在自我整理。
The debates clarify that some people don't have secret candidate charisma powers that are going to reveal themselves at some point. They haven't yet. It might not be happening. So I think that the field probably is going to limit itself more to 16, 17 people soon.
辩论澄清了有些人没有秘密候选人魅力力量，这会在某点揭示出来。他们还没有。它可能不会发生。所以我认为战场可能很快会把自己限制在16、17个人。
When it comes to me taking people seriously, if at this point you had two fundraising quarters, you're in the teens or the high single digits, and you have enough money to fund 50 staff in Iowa, I think that's more interesting. And that's more important than, hey, there's another guy who's at 0%, and he's meeting at a diner.
说到我认真对待人们，如果此时你有两次筹款季度，你在十几岁或高个位数，并且你有足够的钱资助爱荷华州的50名员工，我认为那更有趣。那比，“嘿，有另一个家伙在0%，他在餐馆开会”更重要。
Aw. So the special magical time where it seems like any of the two dozen candidates could rise, that's ending?
噢。所以似乎任何两打候选人都能崛起的特殊神奇时间，要结束了？
It is, except there's a dark horse out there still who could shake things up. There is one more move left in this great game of who will run America.
是的，除非外面还有一匹黑马可能会改变局面。在这个谁将统治美国的伟大游戏中，还剩下最后一步棋。
I know where you're going with this. Yes, on the Republican side, things are still wide open and away. There, it is just the president and so far, one other candidate, former governor Bill Weld. Weld held elective office 20 years ago. He so far has not had much of an impact.
我知道你要去哪儿。是的，在共和党这边，事情仍然很广泛。在那里，只有总统和到目前为止，另一位候选人，前州长比尔·韦尔德。韦尔德在20年前担任过选举职位。到目前为止他还没产生太大影响。
And for our last story, we are joined now by one of our producers, David Kestenbaum. Hey, David.
对于我们的最后一个故事，我们的制片人之一戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆现在加入了我们。嘿，戴维。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，艾拉。
So you talked to two Republicans who are doing basically everything they can to find a genuine heavy hitter to run against the President of the United States from within his own party.
所以你谈到了两位共和党人，他们基本上正在尽一切可能找到一个真正的重量级人物在自己的政党内与美国总统竞争。
Yeah, they feel like if the right person were just to enter the race, it could matter more than anything the Democrats are doing.
是的，他们觉得如果合适的人选进入竞选，这可能比民主党所做的任何事情都重要。
Hm.
嗯。
So here's the scene, an office in Washington, DC.
所以这是场景，华盛顿特区的一个办公室。
Hey, Bill? Hey, Carson. Is Bill out there?
嘿，比尔？嘿，卡森。比尔在外面吗？
That's Sarah Longwell. She's a Republican strategist. The mug in front of her on the desk reads, "These are the tears of my staff." And it's filled with pens. The Bill she is looking for is Bill Kristol, the guy from TV, the one that seems to have an encyclopedic memory of every election in American history. Kristol worked in the first Bush administration, helped start the Weekly Standard magazine.
那是莎拉·朗威尔。她是共和党战略家。她桌上杯子写着，“这是我员工的眼泪。”里面装满了笔。她寻找的比尔是比尔·克里斯托尔，电视上的那个家伙，那个似乎对美国历史上每场选举都有百科全书式记忆的人。克里斯托尔在布什政府工作，帮助创办了《每周标准》杂志。
Oh, you had to stop and get your fancy bougie coffee.
哦，你不得不停下来买你那杯花哨的波西米亚咖啡。
He wanders in and sits down on a small couch. They've just done a poll of voters in New Hampshire, and they're meeting to talk about it.
他溜进办公室，坐在小沙发上。他们刚刚在新罕布什尔州做了一次选民民调，他们正开会谈论这件事。
I mean, look. If I was looking at this thinking about running for the Republican nomination--
我的意思是，看。如果我在考虑竞选共和党提名——
You should do that. I say this all the time.
你应该那样做。我一直这么说。
Yeah, right.
是的，对吧。
We have all these other people we're talking to-- congressmen, and ex-senators, and all these big shots.
我们有所有其他我们在交谈的人——众议员、前参议员，以及所有这些大人物。
This is his great pitch, that I should run. We are really in dire straits, if that's where we're at now.
这是他的伟大推销，我应该参选。如果我们现在处于那种地步，那我们真的处于严峻的困境。
Totally wrong.
完全错了。
I think if you were taking on a standing president from within your own party, there are kind of two paths. You can do it quietly, out of view, or you can do it the way Kristol has-- by never shutting up about it on television and newspaper articles. He recently tweeted that he'd been accused of being in a secret cabal to find a challenger to Trump. His answer-- there's nothing secret about it.
我认为如果你在自己的政党内挑战一位现任总统，有两种途径。你可以静悄悄地，视线之外做，或者你可以像克里斯托尔那样——通过在电视和报纸文章中永远不闭嘴来做。他最近推特说他被指控是一个秘密阴谋集团的一员来寻找特朗普的挑战者。他的回答——关于它没什么秘密的。
Kristol and Longwell have raised a few million dollars in the past two years. And they've been using it to try and see, is this thing even possible? The whole idea of running against Trump in the primary can seem a little crazy. He has like an 80% or 90% approval rating from Republicans. But they feel like it is not crazy at all. In that poll they just had done of Republicans in New Hampshire and independents who might vote in the Republican primary, half were open to voting for a challenger. Half.
克里斯托尔和朗威尔在过去两年筹集了数百万美元。他们一直在用它试图看看，这件事甚至可能吗？竞选共和党初选挑战特朗普的整个想法看起来有点疯狂。他在共和党人中有80%或90%的支持率。但他们觉得这完全不疯狂。在他们对新罕布什尔州共和党人和可能在共和党初选中投票的独立人士进行的民调中，一半人对投票给挑战者持开放态度。一半。
No, I mean, I was just up in Manchester, and I did a series of focus groups. If you ask them specifically, hey, would you be open to an alternative in 2020? Would you like to see another Republican candidate? Every single time, nine out of the 10 hands go up. I think for some people, there's a hunger for an alternative. And then for other people, it's just an openness, like a willingness for political competition.
不，我的意思是，我刚才在曼彻斯特，我做了一系列焦点小组。如果你明确问他们，嘿，你会对2020年的替代方案持开放态度吗？你想看到另一位共和党候选人吗？每一次，10个人中有9个举手。我认为对一些人来说，有一种对替代方案的渴望。然后对其他人来说，这只是开放性，就像一种对政治竞争的意愿。
One thing that really surprises people in these focus groups, she says, is when you explain just how much the debt has gone up under Trump. It's increased more during the first two years of Trump than it did the previous two years under Obama.
她说，当人们解释特朗普领导下的债务增加了多少时，这真的让焦点小组中的人们感到惊讶。特朗普前两年增加的债务比奥巴马前两年增加的还多。
Bill Kristol lays out how this all might go for a challenger. You raise a little money, go to Iowa, New Hampshire. Maybe you get 30% of the vote in New Hampshire. That is a serious blow to the president. You're off and running. So that's their case.
比尔·克里斯托尔列出了挑战者会发生的一切。你筹集一点钱，去爱荷华州、新罕布什尔州。也许你获得30%的新罕布什尔州选票。这对总统来说是一个沉重的打击。你出发了。所以这就是他们的案例。
There is one kind of noticeable challenge to this plan. Since we've had the current primary system, there are zero examples-- zero-- of someone challenging a sitting president in a primary and actually winning.
这个计划有一个相当明显的挑战。自从我们有了目前的初选制度以来，有零个例子——零——有人在初选中挑战现任总统并真正获胜。
I mean, is some part of this just kind of like theater? And I mean theater you truly believe in?
我的意思是，其中一部分只是像戏剧吗？我的意思是，你真正相信的戏剧？
I mean, I don't want to say yes because of course-- because that really isn't. I don't think of it that way. I'm not a very theatrical person. But I guess theater in the sense that presidential politics is the biggest stage we have in politics. And the presidential contest is the biggest stage. And I don't want to simply leave that stage on the Republican side alone to Donald Trump.
我的意思是，我不想说是，因为当然——因为那确实不是。我不那样想它。我不是一个非常有戏剧性的人。但我猜戏剧的意义在于，总统政治是我们政治中最大的舞台。而总统竞选是最大的舞台。我不想仅仅把共和党那边的舞台留给唐纳德·特朗普。
I'm still trying to think through just, like in your mind, why you're doing this. And is part of it just like a feeling like what is democracy for, if I can't cast a vote for the person I really want to be in office?
我还在试图思考——在你的脑子里，你为什么做这个。一部分是因为感觉民主是为了什么，如果我不能把我真正想要的人投进办公室？
Yeah, I think it's actually people are overthinking this. I mean, I'm doing it because I don't think Trump should have a second term. I'm a Republican. It'd be a heck of a thing to say, OK, you think he's really leading the country down a terrible path, and you should just take two or four or six years off.
是的，我想实际上人们过度思考了这个。我的意思是，我做这个是因为我不认为特朗普应该有第二个任期。我是共和党人。如果说，哦，你认为他真的在引导国家走上一条可怕的道路，你应该仅仅休假两、四或六年，那真是太糟糕了。
But you're really unlikely to succeed, right?
但你成功的可能性很小，对吧？
Pretty unlikely to succeed, yeah.
成功的可能性相当小，是的。
So why do it?
所以为什么要这样做？
Look. The last three presidents were not primaried, and they won re-election.
看。过去三位总统没有参加初选，他们赢得了连任。
And here, Bill offered up what seems to be the other math that candidates are doing. The last three presidents did not have a primary challenge, and they won re-election. When a sitting president has been challenged by his own party, like Carter by Kennedy, Ford by Reagan, Bush by Buchanan, the challenger doesn't win. But maybe because they damaged the president, he does not win re-election. In other words, this may be the bargain. You can run for president, possibly shape history, end Trump, change who wins, but you don't get to win.
在这里，比尔提出了候选人们正在做的似乎是另一种数学。过去三位总统没有受到初选挑战，他们赢得了连任。当现任总统受到自己政党的挑战时，比如卡特受到肯尼迪、福特受到里根、布什受到布坎南，挑战者并没有赢。但也许因为他们破坏了总统，他没能赢得连任。换句话说，这可能是这种交易。你可以竞选总统，可能塑造历史，结束特朗普，改变获胜者，但你没有赢得胜利。
I mean, it's interesting. The other Republicans I talked to pointed out that history is not on your side. And you were pointing out, oh, it is on my side, in the sense that a sitting president challenged tends to lose. But that means what you're doing is just an act of internal sabotage.
我的意思是，这很有趣。我谈到的其他共和党人指出，历史并不站在你这一边。而你指出，哦，它站在我这一边，意义在于一位现任总统受到挑战往往会输。但这意味着你正在做的只是内部破坏行为。
No, but I think it's also holding out an alternative in a good way. But yeah--
不，但我认为这同时也是以一种好的方式保持替代方案。但是的——
Or sabotage. I mean--
或者破坏。我的意思是——
Well, people can say that. They said that about the French who didn't go along with Vichy. I mean, what are you supposed to do? If you think it's bad--
嗯，人们可以那样说。他们那样说那些没跟维希政权走的法国人。我的意思是，你应该怎么做？如果你认为这很糟糕——
I love that every time I have a point that's historical--
我喜欢每次我有历史观点的时刻——
If you think it's bad for the country, they can say it's sabotage. I would say it's opposition. I don't think it's sabotage. Sabotage implies secrecy and deception. I don't think there's a heck of a lot of secrecy and deception in what I'm doing. I think I've been pretty open about my opposition, so I feel like I'm-- isn't that the point of America?
如果你认为这对国家很糟糕，他们可以说这是破坏。我会说这是反对。我不认为这是破坏。破坏意味着秘密和欺骗。我不认为我在做的事情里有太多秘密和欺骗。我想我已经对比我的反对非常公开，所以我感觉我是——那不是美国的意义吗？
Honestly, if I were a Democrat, I would call me up and say, here's a lot of money for a primary challenge-- and we have talked to a lot of Democrats about this, obviously-- against Donald Trump. I mean, that's actually the single best thing you can do to weaken Trump. You can help Elizabeth Warren, or Kamala Harris, or Cory Booker right now. But we don't know which of those will actually be a good nominee against Trump. The one thing you do know is if Trump has to spend money against the primary challenger, if he loses 32% of the vote in New Hampshire, which is entirely possible, and it's embarrassing, it would be helpful to weaken Trump.
老实说，如果我是民主党人，我会给我打电话说，给你很多钱进行初选挑战——当然我们已经和很多民主党人谈过这个——挑战唐纳德·特朗普。我的意思是，这实际上是你可以削弱特朗普所能做的唯一最好的事情。你可以现在帮助伊丽莎白·沃伦、卡玛拉·哈里斯或科里·布克。但我们不知道他们中哪一个会真正成为针对特朗普的好候选人。你知道的一件事是，如果特朗普必须花钱对抗初选挑战者，如果他失去32%的新罕布什尔州选票，那是完全可能的，而且这很尴尬，削弱特朗普将是有帮助的。
Wait, but is your goal to run somebody who's going to win the nomination and maybe the presidency? Or is your goal just to take down Trump?
等等，但你的目标是推举一个会赢得提名并可能赢得总统竞选的人吗？还是你的目标仅仅是打倒特朗普？
Both. Obviously, the first would be the best. But I would regard the second as an adequate result, and I think actually an important result, if I can say.
两者都是。很明显，第一个会是最好的。但我会把第二个看作是一个足够的结果，而且如果我可以这么说的话，我认为那实际上是一个重要的结果。
Sarah Longwell has been weighing all this, too. It's possible the whole thing could backfire if the wrong Democrat ended up in the White House.
莎拉·朗威尔也一直在权衡这一切。如果错误的民主党人最终进入白宫，整件事可能会适得其反。
I certainly would not want Bernie Sanders to be the President of the United States.
我当然不希望伯尼·桑德斯成为美国总统。
So if you ended up handing it to Sanders, that would not be a happy day for you.
所以如果你最终把它交给了桑德斯，那对你来说不会是快乐的一天。
Well, that's sort of like, do I want to be poisoned, or do I want to be shot? Those are just sort of bad choices. And I think America deserves better than to have choices between an old socialist and sort of an authoritarian sort of nativist. My choice is neither.
嗯，那就像，我是想被毒死，还是想被枪杀？那些只是一些糟糕的选择。而且我认为美国值得比在老社会主义者和某种威权主义的本土主义者之间做出选择更好的选择。我的选择是两者皆非。
There's this scene in the HBO series on Chernobyl that's running right now where the nuclear reactor is about to explode. So these workers have to go into the basement of the power plant to try to open a valve. There's so much radiation, it seems certain they're going to die, but it will also save everyone else.
目前正在播出的HBO切尔诺贝利系列剧中有这样一个场景，核反应堆即将爆炸。所以这些工人必须进入核电厂的地下室试图打开一个阀门。辐射太严重了，他们似乎肯定会死，但这也会拯救其他人。
Sarah has been watching the show. I asked her if she ever thought about it like that. No, she said. Never. They're not asking someone to risk their life, they're asking someone to put their name in the hat to be the next president of the United States. Apparently, it's easier to get someone to walk into Chernobyl.
莎拉一直在看这部剧。我问她是否曾想过像那样。不，她说。从来没有。他们没有要求某人冒生命危险，他们要求某人把名字放进帽子里成为下一任美国总统。显然，找人走进切尔诺贝利更容易。
[MUSIC - STEVE FORBERT, "YOU CANNOT WIN IF YOU DO NOT PLAY"]
[音乐 - 史蒂夫·福伯特，“如果你不玩就赢不了”]
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and myself. People who put our show together today includes Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Aviva DeKornfeld, Neil Drumming, Damien Gray, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Ben Phelan, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wheeler. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯和我制作。今天安排我们节目的人包括Bim Adewunmi、Emanuele Berry、本·卡尔霍恩、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Whitney Dangerfield、Aviva DeKornfeld、Neil Drumming、Damien Gray、Michelle Harris、Jessica Lussenhop、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Ben Phelan、Catherine Raimondo、Nadia Reiman、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Julie Whitaker和Nancy Updike。我们的总编辑是Diane Wheeler。我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks to David [INAUDIBLE], [? Chris ?] [? Coons, ?] [? Scott ?] [INAUDIBLE], [? John ?] [? Harwood, ?] [? Harry ?] [INAUDIBLE], [? Walter ?] [? Shapiro, ?] [? Ben ?] [? Tourist, ?] the Committee for a Responsible Federal Budget, [? Jamie ?] [? Harrison, ?] [? Andrea ?] [? Gillespie, ?] [? Josh ?] [INAUDIBLE], [? Angela ?] [? Davidson, ?] and [? Jay ?] [? A. ?] [? Moore. ?]
特别感谢David [听不清]、[克里斯] [库恩斯]、[斯科特] [听不清]、[约翰] [哈伍德]、[哈里] [听不清]、[沃尔特] [夏皮罗]、[本] [旅游]、负责任联邦预算委员会、[杰米] [哈里森]、[安德里亚] [吉莱斯皮]、[乔什] [听不清]、[安吉拉] [戴维森]和[杰] [A.] [摩尔]。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 670 episodes. Also, there's videos and tons of other stuff there-- thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流电台提供给公共广播电台。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以流式传输我们超过670集的存档。此外，那里还有视频和大量其他内容——thisamericanlife.org。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he organized a vote this week about what we should have for lunch as a staff. I don't know. He seemed a little too proud of himself.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他本周组织了一次关于我们要午餐吃什么的员工投票。我不知道。他看起来对他自己太骄傲了。
This is what democracy looks like!
这就是民主的样子！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - TOM PETTY AND THE HEARTBREAKERS, "EVEN THE LOSERS"]
[音乐 - 汤姆·佩蒂和伤心人，“即使是失败者”]